What you're about to hear is the sixth
and final part of a six part series on
the first world war.
Traditionally,
we suggest people listen to them in
order,
but I realize not everyone's traditional
and there may be a few historical
dyslexics out there,
and if that's the case,
it might not matter to you the order you
listen in.
If that's the case,
please feel free to jump right in.
And for those of you who've heard the
previous episodes,
welcome back to part six.
As we said,
the final part,
not counting an extra show of blueprint
for Armageddon,
be some bus seven,
19,
41 date which will live in infamy.
Eats
quiet please.
The events
that dude the figure from this time and
place,
I take pride in the words,
been the Alina,
tear down,
complete collapse.
Hi,
welcome.
This kind of examination because people
have got to know whether or not their
president question well,
I'm not a crop.
If we dig deep in our history and our
doctrine and remember we are not
descended from fearful of man.
It's hardcore history.
What's the most dangerous weapon in the
world?
I've had this discussion many times with
many people and I've seen it go all over
the place,
but generally you focus on nuclear
weapons because that's an obvious thing
to put in the number one spot for most
dangerous weapon in the world,
but there are some that are a little bit
more in city,
isn't potentially worse.
Take for example,
biological weapons.
Think about some of the worst plagues
that have ever infested mankind.
Now imagine human ingenuity and a
laboratory use to make such plagues
worse and now imagine releasing those
upon your enemy.
The reason they're so extra dangerous is
because of the way they spread and the
fact that once you open the Pandora's
box of biological warfare,
you generally lose the ability to shut
the box.
Again,
you may exchange a few nuclear weapons
with an opponent and decide to stop.
Once you open up that box and unleashed
super small pox or what have you,
you can't turn that off.
Again,
another reason it's very dangerous is
that super smallpox doesn't
differentiate between the people you
targeted and everyone else that it may
spread to.
It's a bit of a doomsday device.
When you think about how something like
that could backfire on the very people
who decide to use it,
it's a little like deciding to get rid
of your next door neighbor in your
apartment complex by burning down his
place.
The potential for the fire to hurt you
is very real,
but sometimes if you've run out of
options,
gambling like that might make sense.
In late 1917 where we are in this story,
even though we've been using sliding
timescale,
that's about where we are.
In late 1917,
the Germans are desperate enough to try
all sorts of things including the
equivalent of biological warfare,
but instead of using some sort of
contagious disease,
they're using contagious ideas,
but you might be able to make a case
that in this situation an actual disease
would have been preferable.
Whenever I think about this idea,
I think about Napoleon,
the famous French emperor from late 17,
hundreds,
early 18 hundreds who was such a force
in Europe.
Napoleon was someone who spread and
intellectual contagion and I remember
professors in college suggesting that
this was the thing that scared the kings
and czars and emperors of Europe the
most about Napoleon because Napoleon
arose in the wake of the French
revolution,
the era where Frenchman were infused
with these ideas of revolution,
of equality,
of Republican Ism,
all these things that seem in a
relatively moderate to people today,
even beneficial,
but those were the scariest things on
earth to people who were kings and
emperors and czars and many of them
figured that they would eventually be
able to throw the French out of these
territories and get their thrones back,
but they were less sure about their
ability to cleanse their population of
these dangerous radical ideas that
French occupying troops had spread to
them.
In fact,
many historians believe that the famous
revolutionary period in the middle,
18 hundreds was the blossoming of seeds
that were planted by Napoleon's troops.
As they occupied all these countries
talk to the locals and spread the
equivalent of an intellectual contagion.
Of course,
if you're one of those types who would
view the ideas of the American
revolution or the French revolution or
the ideas of the thinkers who helped
prompt those revolutions as a negative
thing than perhaps you would view the 18
hundreds as an example,
not of a seed flowering into some
wonderful plant,
but as a virus beginning to morph and
mutate and evolve into new and maybe
more dangerous forms.
The 18 hundreds is up until that time
period,
almost certainly the greatest period for
intellectual examination of forms of
that's ever existed and part of it is
because of the increase in communication
and how people all over Europe can begin
to have conferences and discussions and
write for magazines and newspapers that
each other reeds and have all sorts of
attempts at trying to apply rationality
and logic to the idea of government.
Because most of the governments in a
place like Europe at this time period
are things that have existed in one form
or another for centuries.
You know,
some one in the distant past was a great
military leader who establishes a
dynasty who rules for hundreds of years
and no one ever really asks whether or
not that's the right thing to do or
whether or not it's smart or anything
else.
In the 18 hundreds,
people began to think along with changes
in science and all kinds of different
things that may be people could come up
with smarter approaches,
but there was wide disagreement though
on what that smart approach might be and
some of the great figures of the 18
hundreds who played roles in this would
become extremely important figures in
the 19 hundreds.
In fact,
someone who was involved in trying to
come up with a system that seemed to be
an improvement over what Europe was
living with in the 18 hundreds explodes
in importance in 1917 exactly where we
are in this first world war story.
He was renowned in his own day within
his own circles,
but he certainly wasn't a household
name.
He becomes a historical superstar in
1917 and there's a little bit of irony.
Did that because in 1917,
this figure has been dead 34,
35 years,
one of the best or one of the worst
aspects of an idea,
depending on whether you consider a good
or dangerous,
is the fact that it doesn't die with the
originator.
In 1917,
all of a sudden everybody starts hearing
the name.
Karl Marx marks is often credited with
being the originator of modern communism
or Marxism,
but I think that's probably giving him a
little too much credit after all,
very few people come up with ideas out
of nowhere and marked like most people
stood on the shoulders of giants with
his ideas.
He was reading guys like the German
philosopher,
Hegel and a lot of other people,
but if a guy like,
hey,
goals and example of the intellectual
contagion than mark's is an example of
someone who mutated it further,
and of course perhaps the ironic tragedy
of marks is that Marx didn't get to be
the implementer of his ideas.
His ideas were adapted and morphed into
different forms.
Like many figures from history.
If you could go back and show Karl Marx
how he's treated in the history books
and the things associated with,
I think he might jump off a bridge.
There's a lot of figures like that who
are remembered for things that are
almost a 180 degrees different than what
they devoted their lives to.
Working for Marx thought he was doing
good and yet today we think about his
role in the deaths of tens of millions
of people and the creation of some of
the worst slave states in all human
history.
If you read Marx and find out what he
was all about,
that's exactly what he was hoping to
prevent and stop and eliminate.
He could bring Carl Marx back from the
dead and have him analyze where things
went wrong.
I wouldn't be surprised at all if he
blamed a botched implementation for the
way things turned out.
We might argue that Marx's ideas from
the get go were poor,
but I think he would probably say that
you never got a chance to see what he
wanted because he wasn't the guy that
built the house.
He was the architect.
May Be or maybe the last guy to design
blueprints.
The guy who actually built the dwelling
was a guy named Vladimir Lenin
and I'm reminded of a quote by the
writer,
Algiers Huxley,
about how ideas end up influencing
people and it's not so much a question
always of how many people but who they
are.
Huxley wrote quote,
it is possible to argue that the really
influential book is not that which
converts 10 millions of casual readers,
but rather that which converts the very
few who at any given moment succeed in
seizing power marks and sorrel have been
influential in the modern world,
not so much because they were best
sellers,
but because among their few readers were
two men called respectively Lennon and
Mussolini and quote
Vladimir Lenin is the hinge point
between theory and application.
When it comes to modern day communism,
he's the implementer.
If mark's is the originator than Lennon
is the implementer and he's a figure
that combines some rather unusual
qualities in one human being.
Oftentimes the intellectual and the deep
thinker and the philosopher is a
different sort of human being than the
person of action.
Right?
You've heard of the man of action,
and oftentimes there are two different
kinds of people.
Lenin is one of these strange
individuals that possesses the qualities
of both an intellectual and a person of
action,
and his dynamic abilities were
recognized even by the people who were
his opponents and take for example the
description of Lloyd George,
the man who is the prime minister of
Britain during the second half of the
first world war,
George will write his memoirs in the
Nineteen Thirties and he will say this
of Latimer Lennon quote,
he was a communist,
but Wilson fanaticism does not always
endow it's possessor with great
administrative ability.
It is not incompatible with a genius for
government and no one can doubt that.
Lennon was one of the greatest leaders
of men ever thrown up in any epic and
the quote.
He then goes on to compare him to what
he calls a plague.
Bacillus.
Lenin was certainly a fanatic.
Most revolutionaries are people who tend
to not see too many shades of gray
things,
tend to be black and white.
Winston Churchill famously defined a
fanatic is someone who can't change
their mind and won't change the subject,
and Churchill had his own opinion of
Lenin and once again it evoked this idea
of an intellectual contagion.
He also compared len into some sort of
bacteria and he blamed the Germans for
unleashing it on Europe,
playing an active role in implementing a
form of germ warfare that would have
horrible effects down the road.
Churchill wrote,
quote,
Lennon was sent into Russia by the
Germans in the same way that you might
send a file containing a culture of
typhoid or Colorado to be poured in the
water supply of a great city and it
worked with amazing accuracy and quote.
That brings us to the third person who
was very important in implementing this
intellectual contagion.
Warfare kind of approach.
The facilitator.
If march is the originator and linen is
the implementer,
Lennon needed some help to get to the
point where he could.
In fact,
if you will,
anyone in the beginning of 1917,
Vladimir Lenin is in exile.
He's living in Switzerland,
next to a sausage factory on the second
floor of a rented flat with his wife
trying to make a living in what you
might call the professional
revolutionary business.
He'd like to get back to Russia in 1917
because it's apparent that huge things
are happening in Russia.
The czar has been overthrown.
A provisional government is taken over,
but Lenin can't get from where he is to
Russia.
There's a war going on and there's a lot
of territory in between Switzerland and
Russia to deal with,
and then he gets some help from the
facilitator,
the leader of Germany's military,
and for the most part by this time,
civilian government,
Eric Luton,
Dorf Ludin
door from the Germans have long been
associated with Lennon's rise to power.
The exact amount of responsibility that
Germany has in that story is debatable
and has been debated since 1917.
One of the reasons historians have a
hard time nailing down definitive
answers is because it's one of those
things that falls into the category of
what we would call today covert
operations or black ops top secret
stuff,
both sides in the war.
We're trying to undermine the
cohesiveness and the stability of their
opponents and it potentially wonderful
way to do that was to give money or arms
or sometimes military advisors to
revolutionaries and insurrectionists and
break away groups and ethnic separatists
and people who lived in countries that
were colonies of some of the great
powers,
but who wanted their independence and
both sides.
As I said,
we're doing this.
There's a lot of allegations about
German involvement.
For example,
in the famous Easter rising in 1916 in
Ireland,
how much German support.
That's questionable too,
and part of the reason why is nobody was
exactly advertising.
Now these top secret affairs,
most of the stories trace German
involvement at least as far back as
1915.
Most of those stories suggests that it
was contacts with leftist individuals
who pointed out to the German government
that there were shared goals on the part
of Germany and some of these Russian
revolutionary figures
take,
for example,
Lennon and his particular offshoot of
the Communist,
you know,
mainstream known as the Bolsheviks.
One of the things Lennon was calling for
was peace.
That's exactly what the Germans wanted
from the Russians.
By 1917,
they wanted the Russians out of the war.
The Russians were tying down millions of
German troops on the eastern front that
the Germans would love to be able to
switch over to the western front to
fight the exhausted French and British
before the Americans arrived in any sort
of decisive numbers.
Now,
the big gamble here of course,
is that the Bolsheviks,
while they may share a common goal in
getting Russia to leave the war,
are not Germany's friends,
Luton Dorf deciding to use them as a
tool,
is akin to adding another boxer into the
World War One.
Boxing match.
We've used that analogy throughout this
series.
The idea of two boxers fighting each
other.
Part of Lewandowski gamble here is he.
He's talking about introducing a third
box or into the ring,
one that wants to fight both the other
two boxers,
but Luton Dorf has a pretty good idea
that he'll go after the one Ludin door
from the Germans are fighting first,
the Bolsheviks and Lennon or preaching
the equivalent of a global civil war.
If the American president,
Woodrow Wilson is calling the first
world war,
the war to end all wars,
Lennon has his own idea of the war to
end all wars is Irish historian William
Mulligan points out Lennon's idea of the
war to end all is revolutionary war.
The Bolsheviks are calling for the poor
and the working classes of all nations
to rise up and overthrow their rulers.
Germany is only a little less vulnerable
to that sort of message.
Then Russia is.
This is why Ludina Dorf is playing with
fire,
or in this case play.
He stands a really good chance of
getting burned by this very same weapon
that he in 1917 decides to help use
against Russia.
The actual means to get Lennon from
Switzerland back to Russia is provided
by the Germans in April 19,
17.
So we're going backwards a little bit in
this story.
The Germans provide a single sealed
train car for Lennon and his cohorts.
Historians have disagreed over who had
demanded that EBC yield.
Some say the Germans wanted this train
car sealed so that when Lennon and his
cohorts are going through Germany,
they don't intellectually infect the
Germans on the way through.
Others say it was Lenin and the
Bolsheviks who demanded it.
The last thing that they wanted was to
have people in Russia find out that they
were accepting help from the country.
Russia was fighting.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
people who happen to be capitalists to
nonetheless,
whomever it was who made the decision as
the train car goes through Germany,
there's a famous incident where Lennon
or one of his cohorts looks out the
window and happens to notice that there
are no mature men anywhere to be seen.
It's children and women and old people.
Germany's mature male population is
either dead or wounded or at the fronts,
Lennon in his party.
Then we'll have to board a ferry and go
by boat for a little bit.
Then they'll get back on another train.
The train will then arrive in Petrograd,
formerly St Petersburg,
the Russian capital just before midnight
on April 16th,
1917.
There will be a crowd waiting to welcome
him because like many other dangerous
radicals,
Lenin is coming home from exile.
The Tsar for decades had been exiled and
all these very formidable intellectual
contagions and those are the ones he
wasn't executing.
By the way,
Lennon's brother had been executed by
the czar.
Now all these people were coming back to
Russia at roughly the same time creating
a seditious soup politically speaking in
Russia during this time period and
believe me,
Russia was ready for it.
They're in this precarious situation
after the czar falls where you have sort
of a moderate government.
I'm known as the provisional government
sharing power with these groups of
soldiers and peasants and workers who
have gotten together and elected leaders
and who are sort of trying to lead from
the bottom and they're sharing power and
not very comfortable sort of an
arrangement with the provisional
government.
It is absolutely a setup for problems
and yet you kind of have to feel a
little bit for them.
I mean,
think about what these people are trying
to do.
They are trying to run a country after
toppling the regime that had been in
power for centuries.
This is a tough thing to do in the best
of times,
but this isn't the best of times.
This is the equivalent of a bus
passenger trying to get ahold of the
wheel when the bus is already careening
off a cliff and then you get a guy like
lennon arriving and he gets off the
platform at a little before midnight and
tells this enthusiastic crowd of
supporters.
The periodical imperialist war is the
beginning of a civil war throughout
Europe.
The worldwide socialist revolution has
already dawned,
Germany is seizing any day now.
The whole of European capitalism may
crash.
Sailors,
comrades.
We have to fight for a socialist
revolution to fight until the
proletariat winds fold victory long live
the worldwide socialist revolution and
quote,
even Lennon's friends thought this way
too optimistic.
In fact,
at that very moment,
the current Russian government power
sharing arrangement was trying to put
together and offensive against the
Germans scheduled for July first with an
army that was sketchy at best.
At this point,
if you are Russia's provisional
government,
you are between a rock and a hard place.
In 1917,
you are barely holding onto power.
You have strikes,
you have unrest,
you have all kinds of problems,
and now you have lennon here taking the
already kind of extreme bolsheviks and
pushing them into greater extremism.
He's calling for three main things that
are impossible for the provisional
government to really contend with.
He is calling for peace,
bread and land,
a triple threat of a message that would
be effective across much of Europe in
1917 and you have the provisional
government,
oh,
it has to prove to the British and the
French that it's still a viable partner
in this war.
They're funneling tons of subsidies to
this government.
In fact,
they need to convince the Germans and
the central powers of the same fact that
you can't just assume we're done and the
best way to do that is to launch and
attack.
The problem is is that this army might
have been willing to stay and defend
mother Russia soil,
but most of them are not willing to go
on the offensive and run into the
machine guns and artillery barrages of
the Germans.
They may not give a hoot about
bolshevism or communism or any of that,
but they understand peace,
bread and land.
On July first,
the Curran ski offensive visits
sometimes called with the July
offensive,
led by the great Russian general Brazil
of launches,
an attack on a wide front against the
Germans and the Austra Hungarians.
It becomes a disaster.
This is the way historian Peter Harte
describes it,
quote,
after a two day bombardment,
the second bruce,
a love offensive attack began with a
flourish with the attack of the Russian
seventh and 11th armies on the southwest
front.
When the infantry went over the top on
first July,
early results were promising,
but then everything started to go wrong.
The best and most loyal units had been
chosen as the assault troops.
While the follow up and reserve
formations were far less committed,
indeed,
when it came to moving forwards,
many regimens simply refused.
The attack petered out in ignominy and
further plan to were either canceled or
abandoned.
Then a vigorous austro-hungarian counter
offensive was launched at Ternopil in
Galicia.
On Nineteenth July,
the Russians broke and retreated in
chaos.
This disaster triggered the replacement
of brucellosis commander in chief by
General Cornell Law.
On the first of August,
the Russian army was falling apart and
such attacks as had been carried out,
only serve to call the few remaining
loyalist units,
still willing to actively prosecute the
war.
The vast majority of Russian soldiers
were now content to be passive
observers.
At best indeed by the autumn,
it was estimated that some 2 million had
deserted and quote for a while the
German high command in the
Austro-hungarian high commanding courage
their troops to fraternize with Russian
troops to sort of undermine their
willingness to fight.
They stopped doing that when they found
out that the Russian troops were
spreading socialist and Bolshevik
propaganda back to the German and
Austro-hungarian troops.
Nonetheless,
what that disaster at the current ski
offensive did was essentially proved
that Russia's army was done and opened
the door even more to the Bolshevik
message calling for peace writer Gj
Meyer describes a letter from Rudolf
Hess,
who in the next World War will be one of
Hitler's henchmen,
writing back to his parents about what
the Russians are doing opposite the
German lines.
They're basically fighting amongst
themselves.
He writes,
quote yesterday,
we saw heavy fighting,
but only among the Russians themselves.
A Russian officer came over and gave
himself up.
He spoke perfect German.
He was born in bodden,
but he's a Russian citizen.
He told us that whole battles are going
on behind their lines.
Their officers are shooting each other
and the soldiers are doing the same.
He founded all too ridiculous.
They can all get lost as far as he's
concerned.
We invited him to eat with us and he
thanked us.
He ate well
and drank plenty of tea before going
off.
There was a lot of noise coming from the
Russian side.
Yesterday.
They were fighting each other in the
trenches.
We also heard shots coming from their
infantry,
but they were firing at each other,
charming and cooled.
Lenin said that the Russian soldiers
were voting for peace with their feet.
The failure of the July offensive was
another nail in the coffin for the
provisional government and added to the
support of Lenin and the Bolsheviks who
were able to portray themselves as the
real alternative to the provisional
government,
the one party that didn't have any
responsibility and what was going on,
and the more Russians didn't like what
was going on.
The more the only choice to change that
seemed to be the bolsheviks.
And over the months between the February
revolution that toppled the czar and
just about November,
the Bolsheviks increased their support
in these councils of peasants and
soldiers and workers known as the
Soviets.
And on November seventh,
19,
17,
they moved in a triumph of superior
organization.
They were able to take over the most
important government buildings in the
Russian capital in a coup that most
Russians awoke to find a fait accompli
already finished.
And the most radical government in power
in a major state since the French
revolution.
All of a sudden,
Lenin and the Bolsheviks were in charge
of Russia and marks and the other 19th
century thinkers we're about to have
their ideas updated,
evolved,
morphed,
and changed,
put into practice in what was about to
become a giant human experiment,
but to most of old Europe,
this looked like a human experiment
conducted by a mad scientist to them.
It looked like the second coming of the
French revolution and Lenin and the
Bolsheviks might as well have been
jacobins.
How long before the guillotines are
brought out and everyone starts getting
their head chopped off.
Within 24 or so hours of taking power,
Lennon starts to make good on some of
his promises.
Understand though Lennon's promises had
a tactical purpose in mind,
they would end up in his mind helping to
spread the revolution to other
countries.
The fire caused by German General Ludin
doors attempt to burn down his
neighbor's apartment.
We're beginning to fan the flames to a
degree where many other countries,
we're likely to get burned Lennon's
decree on land set.
Among other things,
quote,
private ownership of land shall be
abolished forever.
All land shall become the property of
the whole people and into the use of
those who cultivated and cooled.
Then Lennon started spreading the sort
of propaganda that most horrified the
powers who had been fighting the first
world war for more than three years.
By this point,
he said,
quote,
we shall offer piece for the peoples of
all the belligerent countries upon the
basis of the Soviet terms,
no annexations,
no indemnities,
and the right of self determination of
peoples.
At the same time,
according to our promise,
we shall publish and repudiate the
secret treaties and quote the secret
treaties were the treaties amongst the
allied powers that were in the files of
the winter palace and the Bolsheviks had
just taken over by making what was in
those files public.
The Bolsheviks were pulling the
wikileaks maneuver or the Edward Snowden
disclosure of their day.
By the way,
another similarity to the release of the
secret treaties and the Wiki leaks,
Edward Snowden,
revelations of,
of the more modern era are the newspaper
in Britain that released the information
to British readers.
It was the Manchester Guardian that
published in Britain.
The secret treaty information that Leon
Trotsky,
the Bolsheviks,
released to the world,
that's the same newspaper in Britain
that took the lead almost 100 years
later in revealing the Edward snowden
revelations as historians Michael Nyberg
and David Jordan,
right in their history of the eastern
front in the first world war quote,
the Bolshevik leaders had little
interest in working with the capitalist
Western allies.
They soon publish the text of the secret
treaties and diplomatic understandings
that they found in the winter palace and
the government archives.
These agreements showed French and
British support for Russian territorial
gain,
especially at Turkey's expense with
regard to Constantinople.
This seemingly revealed with the
Bolsheviks had been arguing all along,
namely that the war had been fought for
imperial interests,
not out of self defense.
The publication of these terms
embarrassed ally diplomats who had
claimed in public that no such
agreements existed.
This also anchored the Americans who had
advocated a piece without annexations
and quote,
the new Bolshevik government began to
tell generals along the entire front
with the Germans and Hungarians and
Turks,
that they should start making local
peace treaties.
They called for an armistice for 30 days
along the entire front.
All of a sudden,
Russia was in the process of dropping
out of the war.
Lenin is supposed to have said a famous
quote that aptly describes the situation
in November 19,
17.
He said,
quote,
there are decades when nothing happens
and there are weeks when decades happen
and quote and
look at the change in fortune for him
personally.
Six or seven months ago,
he's living in a rented flat on the
second floor next to a sausage factory
in Switzerland.
Now by November 19,
17,
he's basically the guy in charge of the
largest nation on earth,
but this leadership is not uncontested.
A Russian civil war starts almost
immediately with the people who opposed
Lenin and the Bolsheviks and it will go
on for several years and be terribly
bloody and drawing the great powers as
well.
It also will not include $50,
million or more people who are counted
as the citizens of old Russia as some of
these territories begin to break away
from Russia.
Again,
one of the really dangerous things that
the new Bolshevik government professes
is a belief in self determination.
Well,
there are lots of different peoples who
didn't want to be a part of the Russian
government,
perhaps the fins,
the Poles,
the Ukrainians and others who were
starting to think maybe they would just
leave.
They were far from the only peoples who
were members of larger state entities
around the world who thought that they
would like a crack itself determination.
All these European countries that had
colonies were in the same position and
there was no message more dangerous than
the idea that the time had come to
perhaps allow all these people to decide
for themselves whether they wanted to
stay colonies already the plague
bacillus begins to spread and
threatened,
not just the allies and the entente
powers,
but soon the powers that made it
possible for Lenin to get back and start
the fire in Russia to begin with.
This is the point in the story where
Russia and communism veer off into their
own tail,
a very long,
complex tale that impacts the rest of
the 20th century.
You can easily make the case that
perhaps the most important longterm
effect of the first world war is the
collapse of the Russian czar,
an eventual replacement by the
bolsheviks.
It will eventually lead to Joseph Stalin
and the horrors of the Gulag and the
Cold War.
There was a wonderfully prophetic line
around the time of Karl Marx,
so you can see how long before this time
period that revolutionary thinkers like
Bakunin,
we're saying quote,
if you took the most ardent
revolutionary vested him in absolute
power,
within a year,
he would be worse than the tsar himself
and quote and for all his high minded
rhetoric,
very quickly,
Vladimir Lenin was proving Bakunin
right.
But in late 19,
17,
early
1918,
that side of the Bolsheviks and the
communist regime in Russia was still
debatable and unknown.
If you actually read their public
pronouncements,
they look like an almost.
And,
and you know,
in,
in hindsight,
this sounds terrible,
but almost a refreshing group of
idealists who refuse to play by the old
cynical,
hard bitten,
you know,
rules of the European powers.
And to get an idea of how difficult it
is to figure out what's going on there
and what these people are like.
You can look at diaries written during
the time period where people try to make
sense of what they're seeing in Russia.
Take for example,
Evelyn,
Princess Blue Cheer and we've talked
about her before.
She's an English,
a wife of a German nobleman living in
Germany,
and she kept a diary that's often
referred to to give sort of an
impression of what's going on in Germany
and the feelings that they have.
And she writes about this new government
in Russia.
While the peace negotiations to end the
war in the east are going on,
those negotiations will end up with one
of the most one sided treaties and all
history.
It's called [inaudible].
And the only reason it's so one sided is
that the bolsheviks were in such danger
of getting overthrown before they had
consolidated power.
That eventually they just agree to one
of the worst deals of all time.
Assuming that the communist revolution
is soon going to come and sweep all
these western European governments and
central European governments away.
Anyway,
so who cares what they agree to during
the negotiations?
Leon Trotsky and a man we've also quoted
earlier,
a key figure in the Bolshevik government
is negotiating this deal and blue shirt
writes in her diary.
In January in 1918,
the breast litoff's negotiation seemed
likely to come to nothing as Trotsky
seems to be playing a double part and
people say he's only toying with the
central powers to be better able to sow
the seeds of sedition and rebellion
amongst the West European peoples.
They say that already the German
prisoners had been set free in Russia
and that common soldiers are being
placed in command over their former
officers.
She continues quote,
there are many different opinions about
Trotsky here,
some calling him a dreamer and idealist,
others abusing him as a blood thirsty.
Tyrant wills.
There was a whole class of admirers who
declare him to be the greatest man since
Christ lived upon the earth and the
profit of a new religion,
which is to regenerate mankind and
create a new paradise after the delusion
of the war.
Who knows what part this man may be
going to play in the future fates of
Europe,
some 120 years ago people were saying
almost the same things have a certain
unknown little officer who out of the
reign of terror and bloodshed developed
into the vampire emperor who almost
succeeded in draining the blood of all
Europe and quote.
She,
of course,
is referencing Napoleon who grew out of
the French revolution to people at the
time period.
That's what the revolution in Russia
kind of resembled and there are quite a
few similarities that are pointed out by
various historians between the French
Revolution and the Napoleonic era and
the era when the bolsheviks take charge
in Russia.
Take for example,
one of the stipulations that the
Bolsheviks were making during the peace
negotiations at Bressler task.
They wanted their troops to have the
right during the negotiations to
fraternize with the German and Austrian
Hungarian soldiers on the other side of
no man's land.
Why did they want that?
Because they felt that just like
Napoleon's troops spreading the ideas,
the intellectual contagion,
the sedition of the French revolutionary
ideas to the lands of the kings and
Czars and emperors in,
you know,
18th and early 19th century Europe,
the Bolsheviks assumed that their troops
would do the same thing to the Germans
and the ostrow Hungarians in early 20th
century Europe combined that with the
impact that the release of the secret
treaty agreements was having and the
Russian government,
the new Russian government,
the idealistic,
at least on the surface,
new Russian government was doing amazing
damage to the allied war effort by
undercutting all the propaganda and they
had a help.
By the way.
The other really idealistic power that
was starting to have an impact on the
world scene was across the Atlantic.
It was the United States and to the hard
bitten,
cynical Bismarckian,
real politic Europe of that day.
It would have been hard for them to
decide who was more idealistic.
The new Russian Bolshevik government or
the American government of Woodrow
Wilson.
In a sense though,
it's hard to blame,
you know,
Britain and France and these other
European powers for the fact that they
had gone into the war making agreements
with each other and their allies for
carving up this territory or exchanging
that territory because that was standard
operating procedure when the war started
and had been,
you know,
forever.
The 19th century is full of those kinds
of conflicts.
The problem is in just a couple of
years,
things have changed in so many ways.
The first world war is that
transitionary period from the 19th to
the 20th century and that includes
things like the proper and moral
justifications for war.
I'm part of the problem is that for
three years now,
the allies,
to name just one example,
the central powers were doing similar
things,
had made the war aims out to be these
high minded ideals,
right?
The war to end all wars or making the
world safe for democracy or fighting,
you know,
German militarism.
I mean there were all these very high
minded ideals.
So when you sell people on those ideas,
when they find out that really what
those soldiers are dying for is much
more pedestrian,
you know,
sorts of ames,
it's hard to square those two realities.
In fact,
there were nations involved in the first
world war that essentially had joined
sides with,
you know,
the,
the alliance that promised them the best
outcome.
Italy,
Bulgaria,
Romania,
to name just three countries got into
this war for no other reason than,
you know,
one side or the other,
promise them some territorial gain that
was more than the other side promised
them.
That was a very common reality from the
19th century.
Part of what changed that and made it
unacceptable was the price that Europe
was being forced to pay for these
territorial acquisitions.
I mean,
a perfect example is 20 years before
this time period where we are now
instead of 19,
17,
eight,
late 1917.
Imagine you're in 18,
98 and you're the British army in an
area that's going to become part of,
you know,
your colonial,
the territories that you have direct or
indirect control over in the modern
nation of Sudan.
There was a very big battle called
Omdurman fought in 18,
98.
Winston Churchill was there as a very
young man.
His first real exposure to violence,
I think he killed a couple of people in
that battle,
honor Omdurman had about 8,000
or so British troops and then they had a
bunch of allies of theirs from Egypt and
places like that.
Natives is not the right word because
you think of like tribesmen but,
but but troops from Egypt and they were
fighting people who were kind of
tribesmen a bunch of Sudanese under.
I'm a leader in that country,
more than 50,000
of them show up to this battle against
this small group of,
of British and British allies and using
modern weaponry,
including basically machine guns,
modern rifles.
I mean it's essentially in a Beta
version of the first world war army that
Britain goes to war with and they're
fighting guys who have muskets
practically and in one afternoon they
inflict some 30,000
or more casual to use on the tribesmen
and folks that they're facing.
10,000
dead,
5,000
captured the rest wounded and the
British lose 45 to 50 British soldiers
in the endeavor,
45 to 50 and they just demolished this
native force when you're only losing
that number of people for such great
gains.
Sometimes you don't always think too
much about the deeper questions involved
in the cost because the cost isn't that
great and let's be honest,
in this era,
if those British soldiers had been
wiping out Frenchman or Germans or
Swedes are people like themselves,
there might've been more of an outrage.
It was an era where sometimes the
killing of native peoples in other
places was not given the same sort of a
sense of horror and outrage that killing
people who looked like yourself might
engender.
We all understand how that might work.
And so instead of a battle of Omdurman
where the changing of territory was it
relatively small affair with relatively
few casualties.
You know,
in late 1917,
the Germans and the British in just one
battle in this war,
you know,
suffer between 200 and 500,000
casualties each.
You think of deeper,
different,
more fundamental questions when you not
only suffer casualties like that,
but you do so over and over and over
again with no appreciable change,
nothing,
certainly worth all that and you begin
asking fundamental questions about these
treaties.
You wrote an earlier time in this war,
how many Frenchman is it worth losing to
regain the lost territories of Alsace
and Lorraine,
how many German young people is it worth
to hold onto Belgium?
How many Austro-hungarian troops or
conversely Italian troops you know is
that particular area near [inaudible]
worth?
How many diminutive lives in Indian
lives in British lives?
Is postwar British involvement in the
Middle East worth?
Well,
if it's the battle of Omdurman and we're
talking tiny numbers,
it's certainly worth it.
There's a number that you're going to
get to when it's not
and the first world war challenges a lot
of people to ask those kinds of
questions and the people that were
operating under the same sort of
mentality that would have been present
at a battle of Omdurman are red faced.
When these treaties show up,
showing that that's just what they're
like.
They haven't changed yet and the
treaties are going to have to be
fulfilled anyway.
Meanwhile,
if you didn't feel bad enough in late
1917 when the bolsheviks released this
information in January of 1918 in part
because the bolsheviks did release this
information,
President Woodrow Wilson in the United
States released something called the 14
points.
Now the 14 points,
if it's,
if the Bolshevik move that makes the
rest of the world looked like a bunch of
capitalists,
warmongers is like a left hook.
The American move in 1918 in January.
It's like a right cross right afterwards
to all these European old powers because
the United States hitting from,
from the other side of the idealism
scale are suggesting that you should
have a war based on things like mutual
respect.
Woodrow Wilson says Nice things,
for example about the Germans and how
the Americans and the rest of the world
do not begrudge the Germans a shot at
German greatness and all this kind of
stuff.
In other words,
conciliatory stuff.
If you're trying to have a deal and make
everybody come to the table feeling
like,
yes,
we can work together,
but if you're the French and you've
already suffered more than a million
casualties against these people,
you had a war against them.
Regeneration in the past.
I mean you're not really in the mood to
be very conciliatory and then Wilson
starts talking about stuff that's as
idealistic as anything the Bolsheviks
are putting out and a lot of it sounds
very similar.
For example,
here's how Wilson leads into his 14
points and notice how often he talks
about a change in you know,
what we could maybe call today global
public opinion or international morality
and values.
He says from the beginning of his
statement that's gone down in history as
the 14 points quote,
it will be our wish and purpose that the
processes of peace when they are begun
shall be absolutely open and they shall
involve and permit henceforth no secret
understandings of any kind.
The day of conquest and aggrandizement
is gone by.
So it was also the day of secret
covenance entered into in the interest
of particular governments.
And likely at some unlooked for a moment
to upset the peace of the world.
It is this happy fat now clear to the
view of every public man whose thoughts
do not still linger in an age that is
dead and gone,
which makes it possible for every nation
whose purposes are consistent with
justice and the peace of the world to
avow,
nor at any other time the objects it has
in view.
And he then goes into you know the kinds
of things he's talking about here that
will make a difference in the postwar
world and that everybody should start to
agree to.
He says,
as the number 1:14,
number one point in the 14 points,
quote,
open covenance of peace openly arrived
at after,
which there shall be no private
international understandings of any
kind,
but diplomacy shall proceed always
frankly,
and in the public view.
And to quote,
can you imagine even the governments of
our world today?
Even talking about doing that,
the idea that Jews had treaties with
other countries and all the agreements
should be public and open to everyone.
I mean,
that's radical stuff.
Even today,
it sounded every bit like what the
Bolsheviks were calling for and all of a
sudden you have all Europe.
The three,
four,
five years ago was sitting at the height
of his fame.
Everything was fine and now they've got
this on both sides of them from powerful
nations.
It's a real change in attitude.
As I said,
though it's not going to be allowed to
change agreements that countries have
between each other and the juiciest
stuff that came out of these secret
treaty released the the Edward Snowden
like dumped to the Manchester Guardian
and others was the treaties that had
been signed.
Some of them as late as 1916,
the most famous is known as the Sikes
Pico agreement,
but there are others that catalog the
great powers plan for ripping apart the
Ottoman Empire.
If the great powers on the allied side
won the war,
they were going to go totally imperial
on the old empire.
The Russians were going to finally,
after hundreds of years of wanting it
get constantinople,
Istanbul later byzantium.
Once upon a time,
this great city,
the controls,
you know,
the Dardanelles and the Bosphorus and
the,
you know,
the access to the Black Sea would be a
huge coup.
The Russians were prevented from doing
this by the very British and French that
they were now negotiating with to get it
in the 18 fifties in the Crimean war,
which propped up the Ottoman Empire for
another generation,
but now the Russians were on the same
side as the French and the British.
They had all decided that the Ottomans
had to go and they were all going to
agree on what pieces they got.
Now,
the payoff for the Russians getting
constantinople on the regions around
that was that the French and the British
would get to carve up much of what is
now the modern Middle East.
I just don't write me the email.
I know that even saying the term Middle
East is a reference to their colonial
past in that region because really if
you were going to announce it properly,
you should call it West Asia or
something like that,
but that doesn't really denote the exact
area you're talking about.
You could get into the,
the,
the areas,
I bet you could say double the lavant or
Anatolia or Mesopotamia,
but those are all just pieces of the
term Middle East encompasses.
So I apologize.
I know it's not the right phrase.
Nonetheless.
We all know what we mean and certainly
if we're going to talk about the era
where Middle East becomes the colonial
term for the era,
why not start with the era where it
becomes a colonial possession for non
Islamic powers,
the Sikes,
Pico agreement and others have France
carving up large chunks of the modern
Arab world and the British taking
northern Iraq and I mean the,
the breathtaking they really are.
And when the Bolsheviks released the
secret treaties and the Ottoman
government reads the secret treaties to
their own,
you know,
group of,
um,
nobles is the wrong word,
but governmental ministers,
um,
Eugene Rogan says in his book that
there's this audible gasp as they hear
the plans that France and Britain and
Russia have,
you know,
for the future of the Ottomans,
it's not going to be a slap on the
wrist.
It's going to be dismemberment.
And the dismemberment of the Ottoman
empire is what creates the modern Middle
Eastern world that is still such a part
of our lives today.
I had said earlier that the Bolshevik
revolution was probably the top,
you know,
long lasting after shock from the first
world war.
But maybe it's better to say that
there's a list of three or four possible
claimants to the throne,
if you will.
And maybe another one is the changes
that are created in the Middle East
because the Ottoman Empire is broken up.
Let's remember,
this is a 600 year old empire.
It's hard to overstate how long the
structures and the type of rule by the
Ottoman impacted that area.
First of all,
it was a large area that was under
Muslim control with a caliphate on paper
at least.
And the leader of the religion,
at least the Sunni branch of it in
Turkey,
the Turks ruled that region with an iron
fist.
And yet at the same time it was in the
process of having huge debates over
modernization and keeping up with the
rest of the world.
And they were just a few years from
finding out that they sat at the top
some of the world's greatest deposits of
oil on the planet,
which some more conspiratorial
historians will will weave into the
story and point out that it wasn't an
accident that the French and the
British,
for example,
we're deciding that it was worth tearing
up the Ottoman Empire at this point,
but if they hadn't and somehow the
Ottoman empire existed in another 10 or
20 years,
think about the inheritance it was about
to come into as a giant multiethnic
Islamic state with oil wealth coming
into the.
I mean it just.
It's fascinating to ponder how different
the world might be,
but if you're a member of the government
of autumn,
Turkey,
when you hear the news about how you're
going to be dismembered as part of these
secret agreements that become public,
you're getting that information about a
week,
maybe even a little less than a week on
the heels of some other information.
That's sort of.
Should have warned you that this was
coming because everybody awoke to a
declaration that was published on
November second,
1917.
That appeared in a bunch of newspapers
and kind of went viral,
I guess you could say by the standards
of the early 20th century and the
statements said this quote,
His Majesty's government view with favor
the establishment in Palestine of a
national home for the Jewish people and
will use their best endeavors to
facilitate the achievement of this
object.
It being clearly understood that nothing
shall be done,
which may prejudice the civil and
religious rights of existing non Jewish
communities in Palestine or the rights
and political status enjoyed by Jews in
any other countries and to quote so you
get that on November second,
you get the news on the eighth or the
ninth.
You know about the sites,
Pico agreement in the others that don't
just tear up your empire and give it to
the victorious powers if they're going
to be victorious,
that's still up in the air,
but also gives it to peoples who are
currently in your empire.
Now,
most notably Arab people in a very
similar move to what the Germans had
done when they sent Vladimir Lenin to go
into Russia and destabilize that
country.
The British had been working with
subjects of the Ottoman empire and
encouraging them to rebel.
There were a couple of important Arab
tribal leaders that were already sort of
thinking along those lines and may have
had contact with the British even before
war broke out,
who by 1915,
19,
16 were convinced to rebel against the
Ottoman overlords.
They had a lot of British help.
They eventually went from a bunch of
ragtag gorillas to a a relatively nasty
guerrilla force in the region.
Although the impact that they had on the
war has been argued about forever with
historians.
It's a very colorful story.
It involves this person that's called
Lawrence of Arabia.
They made a movie about him,
but there's a lot more to that,
including the most important people,
which were these two tribal families
that the British were able to convince
to rebel against the Ottomans,
both of whom were important.
One controlled the area around Mecca.
The other had a name now graces the
front of the country that occupies the
Arabian peninsula.
Saudi and the other family put kings on
the thrones of multiple post World War
One,
Middle Eastern nations.
The kings of Iraq came from this family,
the kings of places like Jordan,
the current king of Jordan is a
descendant of this family.
And that power emanated from this first
world war,
throwing their lot in with the allies
and then,
you know,
reaping the reward.
Now,
it should be pointed out that the reward
was not what they'd planned and the
British after the war found themselves
in a rather uncomfortable position when
they realized that they had promised
multiple things to multiple people.
And oftentimes it was the same stuff.
This will lead to some embarrassing
moments after the war,
uh,
over questions about fine print and what
was really sad and meant a Sir Henry
Wilson who was the chief of the imperial
general staff in 19,
19 will tell another British general
quote.
We have made so many promises to
everybody in a contradictory sense that
I cannot for the life of me see how we
can get out of our president mess
without breaking our word to somebody
and quote.
And it's easy to see why the Arabs had
been promised things and what it was
hoped that they would do the rebellion.
What's been more argued about in is more
interesting for historians,
is trying to figure out what was,
what was to be achieved by the Balfour
Declaration.
And there are so many different
rationales that have been put forward.
That could be a study,
an interesting show in and of itself.
I mean,
it runs the gamut too from people who
are suggesting that the reason the
British throw their weight behind,
you know,
a Jewish homeland in Palestine has to do
with a personal relationship with the
Jewish guy who helped,
you know,
make it easier to create a weapon.
There's another theory that it was hoped
that they could have a,
the British,
one of the friendly people to occupy
this important area to sort of help
guard Britain's imperial possessions in
places like India.
But my favorite of the many,
many theories out there for why the
Balfour Declaration,
this important benchmark moment in the
history of modern Zionism happened.
My favorite is the antisemetic reason
that it might've happened that some
people put forward,
which is that there were both a
combination of real antisemites out
there and people who were pretty
educated in pretty sure that it was just
a canard when people said the Jews ruled
the world,
but just in case it wasn't,
wouldn't it be worth it just to be on
the safe side if we made sure that
Jewish public interest the world over
was on our side.
In fact,
the British were even worried about
rumors that the Germans were going to
offer the Jews a homeland if Jews sort
of signed on with the German cars and so
in an effort to make sure that if the
Jews controlled the world,
they were on our side,
that we were going to have a statement
made that said,
we supported a return to Palestine for
Jewish folks.
I love that.
Without that,
just that's the most perverse of all the
excuses,
but nonetheless,
what it did was plant a seed that later
on we all understand will grow into,
you know,
the modern Middle East that we have
today.
There's also that one other little
element that of course plays a role in
this story.
We mentioned it a little bit ago that
turns this region from what you easily
could have suggested might be a
backwater in the middle of nowhere after
the war was over with some important
religious sacred sites and whatnot,
but not much going on in the way of
resources or value or anything where the
great powers on the world stage would
care much for this area and instead
transforms this region into perhaps the
most strategically valuable spot on the
planet.
It's because all of a sudden the world
realizes the importance that oil and
petroleum is going to play in the 20th
century world and everybody's sort of
realize it at the same time.
It's one of my favorite parts of the
first world war story too,
and it's so hard to figure out what
people knew when there had been
visionaries all throughout the
development of the 20th century.
Realization that oil was going to be
huge.
I mean,
they start pumping this stuff and the
1840 [inaudible],
50 [inaudible],
18 sixties and a bunch of different
places and refining it,
and the main reason it's important in
the 18 hundreds.
Remember the 18 hundreds is part of the
industrial revolution.
The industrial revolution was a
revolution that functioned mostly with
coal as the energy source.
Although steam was also used,
the people that are making the decisions
in the first world war are going to be
men in age groups who grew up in a world
powered by coal and steam
oil was becoming quite valuable,
but for different reasons than energy.
Well,
I guess you could still say it was
energy was.
It was an illumination source and a lot
of places they used it for light.
They also used it for lubrication and
oil,
but people did foresee what maybe you
could call the vehicular revolution that
the first world war would so plainly
sort of put on steroids.
It was coming anyway,
but you know how war tends to speed up
technological progress because while
it's life or death,
one of the famous stories of the first
World War is the famous battle of the
Marne story of the taxi cabs of Paris
lining up to ferry troops to the very
hot spot on the battle front that was in
near danger of breaking.
This is all the romantic story that
helps illustrate one of the really early
trends in the first world war,
the use of vehicles in to change the
situation on the battlefield for all of
human history.
Men have either been walking themselves
or utilizing,
you know,
natural animal power in this battle.
They were starting to use things that
were powered by gasoline and you would
go from cars and taxi cabs,
two trucks,
two tanks.
You'd have aircraft try to imagine,
and I'm sure Leonardo Davinci could do a
great sketch of it in the renaissance,
but try to imagine aircraft that were
coal or steam powered.
You kind of needed this dense,
portable energy source that became part
of internal combustion engines and all
this stuff sort of happened during the
war.
The visionaries had been people like
Churchill who had said convert the
British fleet to oil burning instead of
coal.
He was ahead of his time in like 19.
Oh eight.
The British government was making deals
with an oil company in Iran.
It's called the Anglo Persian oil
company.
It was very powerful and very important
for a long time,
but once again shows that some people
were on top of this or as some
historians have suggested,
they may have just been doing this for
the lubrication and illumination value.
They may not have foreseen the vehicular
revolution either,
but once it strikes,
you know,
even people who aren't all that
visionary can see,
oh my gosh,
you know,
oil is the coal of the 20th century.
And I often think to myself,
you know,
if you found the oil of the 21st
century,
some clean burning immensely wonderful
replacement to oil that could do all
these fantastic things,
but it only appeared in a few separate
isolated regions.
Around the globe,
what do you think the governments of the
world would do today about that?
I mean here I've been critical of the
great powers for some of the horse
trading that was apparent in all their
war aims and have probably
overemphasized that to a degree
considering how much geopolitics did
play a role in economics,
did play a role.
The first world war had a lot of reasons
and the reasons that countries got into
it had a lot of different causes and
nuances as well,
but it's the horse trading nature of
territories that seems to stand out so
much to modern.
It does make me think however,
that if that 21st century version of oil
were found tomorrow,
but in limited amounts and in limited
areas,
you know,
I do wonder whether our governments
would act any differently in terms of
the way they would approach it.
Then that first world war leadership,
if anything,
I would imagine that what they learned
from the first world war is not what to
do or what not to do,
but perhaps have a better sense of how
you justify what you do in the first
World War Two,
our modern sensibilities and to the
changing sensibilities of the time.
It all seemed a little too naked
sometimes once it was exposed to the
light of day and yet it's hard to blame
any of these powers for doing whatever
it took to see to it that you could get
yourself some of this new 20th century
version of coal because it could
literally be a matter of life or death
in terms of remaining a great power and
as normally happens in the lottery for
natural resources.
Some places we're blessed with lots of
this stuff and other places with almost
none.
The United States is one of the first
places where the first grade,
I mean it's the Saudi Arabia of the
first grade oil boom.
I mean the United States.
They find it in Pennsylvania initially
and then in a ton of other places.
The United States is one of the great
oil producing nations of all time and
they really come into their own right
when the oil really takes off.
Very,
very late 18,
hundreds,
early 19 hundreds.
Russia also has some wonderful reserves
that have been under development from
very early on in Baku in places in
what's now a parts of Azerbaijan and the
problem they were having of course,
as this Bolshevik revolution,
a lot of these out of the way places on
the Russian periphery.
We're deciding maybe to go on their own
and take the oil with them,
so temporary problems for the Russians
in who,
but what that does is create a situation
where there's a giant wonderful supply
of oil sitting there with no big
government controlling it temporarily
because the bolsheviks yeah,
their whole thing is in disorder and
they're trying to get a handle on things
and they're preaching self determination
and people are taking them up on the
offer.
And Bach,
who was all of a sudden you're going to
break away and become part of some maybe
Azerbaijani state.
That is just too much of a temptation
for a bunch of great powers that look at
it and think,
I bet I could get there with an army if
I tried hard enough and what if we could
seize the oil fields of buck?
Who the only other good source anywhere
around Europe was in Romania and about
1917.
All the great powers realize we got to
get ourselves some oil and the British
and the French and the Germans.
Three of the great powers on the world
stage.
When the first world war started,
none of them have good access to large
amounts of oil.
It's hard to suggest that there is any
bigger national security concern for
those nations at this point than to
secure themselves a supply of this
century's great energy source and the
one that's needed to power the most
cutting edge weapons that you need to
win any war.
It's easy to be critical
of these people pursuing these kinds of
policies,
but look at what the stakes are and from
a purely real politique down and dirty
standard,
the arguments for imperialism in this
case make a certain kind of sense.
I mean what they're saying,
for example,
amongst British politicians,
some of whom do not want to go in and
control these areas.
The prime minister before the current
prime minister in 1917,
Herbert Asquith,
you know,
he didn't want anything to do with this
region and all of its problems and
factionalism.
I'm in the Arab tribes that were
fighting,
fighting on Britain's side as part of
the Arab revolt.
We're only part of the Arabs out there.
There were a lot of other areas that
were very loyal to the Ottoman
government.
You had a Sunni and Shiite issues to
deal with.
I mean to to ask what it looked like,
a hornet's nest,
but he had a hard time fighting against
the people on the other side of the
argument who were making the point that
you were then going to simply see
whatever could be taken from the
Ottomans.
Once they were gone to your great power
rivals mean the French will go in then
and take the oil perhaps,
and then they're strengthened while you
are weakened and you don't have any
access to.
The Cole of the 20th century has asked
with eventually said,
you know,
he said,
quote,
if we were to leave the other nations to
scramble for Turkey without taking
anything ourselves,
we should not be doing our duty.
End Quote,
well,
if not,
having access to your own oil meant that
your country would fall to a second
class status.
I think there would have been a lot of
people in Britain,
a democratic government who would have
said that it was their politicians duty
to see that that didn't happen.
Now the last time we checked in with the
story in the Middle East and all that
area concerning the Ottomans fighting
against the British and the French and
the British Dominion troops from places
like India and South Africa and
Australia and New Zealand and places
like that,
that the war hadn't been going
particularly well.
The Turks were tough.
They put up a pretty darn good
resistance for a country that was
supposed to be basically done,
having just fought a couple of wars
previously,
economics.
We're in a disaster and everything,
and instead the Turks put up a pretty
darn spirited resistance.
They've got the Germans in there helping
them to,
you know,
modernize a little here and there and
the British simply were not and who
could be for the logistical challenges
that trying to maintain large armies,
which the British didn't tend to
maintain in the field anyway,
throughout their history,
in the middle of the desert,
the challenges were huge.
The Turks were tough.
The British essentially had to retreat
from politically.
They got trapped in a place called
[inaudible],
like we told you in an earlier episode
and had to surrender.
It was not exactly their finest hour,
but in their defense,
most of their effort is in the meat
grinder area.
On the western front.
This is an area that some people
referred to as a side show,
and this gets back to the argument we've
mentioned earlier between those in the
allied camp that called themselves or
were called Westerners and the others
who were called easterners,
people whose ideas said that the western
front,
the meat grinder is the focal point of
the war.
It's going to be decided there,
so taking troops and sending them to any
other part of the war is to work against
what you need to be doing,
which is breaking through it.
The key point,
the other group,
the easterners believed that throwing
troops into the meat grinder where
things were stalemated was a callus
waste of lives when there were
vulnerable points all on the rest of the
map.
That could be exploited,
easier places to go.
Winston Churchill in the Second World
War was always looking for the soft
underbelly of Europe was the way the
phrased was turned.
In the first World War,
there were easterners looking for the
soft underbelly of Europe and the best
argument I've ever heard for who was
right because I was looking at Lloyd
George,
his memoirs the other day and you know,
20 years after the war,
he still justifying and wagging a finger
in the face of the westerners saying we
were right and the westerners are saying
that they were right.
The German General Ludina [inaudible]
had pointed out that yes,
the West and the western front meat
grinder was where the war would be
decided,
but if there was a catastrophe on any of
the other fronts in the war that that
would impact German power on the western
front leading to a loss there so that
they were interconnected.
All these non western front battles are
sideshows.
Unless those fronts collapsed and then
it's a disaster.
In 1917.
The British who have changed generals
and who have now put a meticulous effort
into just slowly but surely building up
the infrastructure that you need to
maintain an army in the field.
They're mean.
Just think of the pipelines of water
that they build for miles upon miles
upon miles to go out to where the troops
are going to have to be in trench lines.
I mean the amount of effort that's
required,
the buildup of troops and everything
else,
but by 1917 they begin to push the Turks
back everywhere.
You're 19,
17,
and especially the latter half of the
year,
sees multiple victories on the part of
the British led allied forces in places
like Mesopotamia
and Palestine,
lots of outflanking,
some wonderfully clever spy maneuvers
and some fantastic bravery and audacity
on the part of some of these dominion
mounted infantry forces.
For example,
end up creating a situation where the
British high command can see Jerusalem,
the holy city of holy cities,
right sacred to at least three major
religions,
Islam,
Christianity and Judaism.
They can see Jerusalem within range and
they know that they're going to take it
if this,
you know,
momentum continues,
but after dealing with passion Dale and
the mud and the blood and the shock and
the sense of never ending war,
which just wraps up in mid November.
Lloyd George asks,
British General Allenby if he can manage
to capture the holy city by Christmas,
says it will be a great Christmas
present for the British people.
A little pick me up if you will.
After all of the horribleness,
Lloyd George gets his wish granted on
December 11th with the British and
allied forces already in the city,
they receive a surrender notice from the
Turkish representative who writes,
quote,
due to the severity of the siege of the
city and the suffering that this
peaceful country has endured from your
heavy guns and for fear that these
deadly bombs will hit the holy places.
We are forced to hand over to you,
the city through Hussein Al Husseini,
the mayor of Jerusalem,
hoping that you will protect Jerusalem
the way we have protected it for more
than 500 years
and quote doesn't that note sort of
bring it all home in terms of the
immense age of some of these nation
states that we're dealing with here.
There's a ton of irony and symbolism.
When the allied forces captured
Jerusalem,
start with the fact that Christians had
captured Jerusalem before in 10,
99 during the first crusade was a very
big deal at the time,
followed by a terrible massacre,
but the Christians managed to hold the
city for a couple hundred years.
The Islamic general salary in the great
occurred by the way we'll retake the
city during the third crusade and the
late 12 hundreds.
There will be a major crusade in the
Middle Ages launched against these very
Ottomans.
You know when there are a lot younger
and more vigorous of an empire,
and now Christian forces were once again
moving into this city,
the propaganda
possibilities of an event like this are
huge,
but it also has some real world postwar
implications.
You know that old line that possession
is nine tenths of the law?
Well,
that will certainly be the case after
the war when the British are involved in
not always wonderfully nice negotiations
with the French and people are locals in
that region over who gets what.
There had been some agreements during
the war that Palestine and Jerusalem
should be internationalized.
The British didn't like that idea as
much after the war and since they were
the ones governing there since December
19,
17,
gave them a unique ability to decide how
things were going to go,
so important in a real world sense to
the entire affair and its importance of
the entry into this holiest of cities
was understood and stage manage to a
degree.
The British government had some ideas on
the way we would say today,
the optics or the visual should go in
18,
98,
the German emperor,
the Kaiser had visited Jerusalem again
with lots of visuals and optics and lots
of photographs and lots of propaganda
benefits for doing so,
and he kind of offended some of the
religious folks by not really seeming
humble enough in the face of such
intense sacredness for three of the top
religions on the planet.
There was even a story that the Turks
had to destroy a part of the ancient
old,
you know,
Israeli part of the walls to make room
for the Kaiser's car.
So He.
So he could bring the car in.
Whether or not that's true,
it certainly made him look bad and
before Alan b becomes the first
Christian conqueror in more than 500
years to walk into Jerusalem,
he gets a little advice from British
General Robertson who tells him in a
telegram quote in the event of Jerusalem
being occupied.
It would be of considerable political
importance if you on officially entering
the city dismount at the city gate and
enter on foot German emperor Rodin,
and the same went round a better man
than he walked.
Advantage of contrast in conduct will be
obvious and quote by December 19,
17.
It looks as though it won't take a whole
lot for the British and the French and
the dominion forces to strike at the
Turks and just sort of pushed the entire
house of cards over.
And in some ways the Turks are not doing
themselves any good because when the
Russians pulled out of the war,
it leaves a ton of territories that have
lots of Turks in it.
You know,
open for Turkish conquest.
And the Turks are sending armies that
might be better used against the British
and the French into this territory were
places like Armenia and Azerbaijan and
all those places are in order to get new
territory while they're losing old
territory.
Nonetheless,
whether or not the French and the
British can just push over the house of
cards now becomes a bit of a moot point
because very early into 1918 when the
finishing touches on any idea to do that
would have to be in play.
All of a sudden everything is needed
back on the western front.
Allenby is going to have his forces,
his best forces ripped from him and no
reinforcements or extra force is added
because all of
a sudden,
just when everything looked like the
United States was going to come in and
turn the tide of the war,
the Germans attempt to turn the tide of
the war first and we mentioned before
the real differences in sorted the feel
and the ebb and the flow and the rhythm
of the two world wars.
The first and the second world wars in
the Second World War.
There was a certain point where where
the outcome of the war was no longer in
doubt,
but it was quite a ways between that
moment and the end of the war,
you know,
it's probably safe to say like late 19,
43,
everyone knows that the Germans in their
site or not winning that war,
no one knows how many people are going
to have to die before the outcome is
finally settled,
but everyone knows what the outcome's
going to be.
You can concoct some real,
real long shots scenarios where the
Germans for example,
get atomic weapons first or something
like that and change the course of
history,
but by and large it was a moot point
past a certain period,
probably late 43.
As I said,
the first world war.
His rhythm was completely unlike that.
There were,
you know,
if you wanted to say who had the
advantage.
Most of the time it was the allied
forces continually putting their weight
on the other side and wearing them down,
but the other side led by Germany would
strike out and lash out at certain times
with huge blows.
No,
that easily could have knocked the other
side out.
The last of these Germany throws in
early 19,
18.
Even the members of Germany's,
you know,
upper military caste.
We're calling it the last card.
Now I have to set a few things up before
we understand about this last card
situation.
The first is understanding where the war
is at this point.
Germany's got some good stuff happening
and some bad stuff happening.
We just mentioned one of the bad things.
The situation with their Turkish ally in
the Middle East is starting to turn for
the worst,
right?
The latter part of 1917.
Not so great,
but that is offset by good things that
had been happening in that same time
period.
We've said is so important.
October,
November,
December.
In 1917,
the Germans send,
actually not that much,
but it made a big difference.
Some help to their austro-hungarian
allies who have been fighting the
Italians forever in the region of the
river is Sanzo.
They have had 11 battles of the zero to
this point in the war,
so you can tell how much things are
moving.
Right?
It's a stalemate on these Alpine peaks
and they're cutting,
you know,
hideouts into the ice.
It's this crazy alpine war they're
fighting,
but both sides are really tired and the
Italian troops are really tired of,
of the guy who's been running the show
for them,
the general in charge of,
of their effort.
He's really sort of a stickler and
they've had it with them and they and
they've been like their austro-hungarian
enemies putting up with a lot for years
and a lot of senseless deaths.
It's just been,
it's been terrible.
And then all of a sudden the German
send,
you know,
seven or eight divisions there to act as
sort of the edge of another offensive.
The twelfth I Sanzo but it gets known by
a different name because it stands out
from the other 11 battles of the
assault.
So it's often called the battle of
corporate.
Righto.
And the reason it stands out from the
other battles of the Assad is because
this time something decisive happens,
the Italians get smashed and who can
blame them?
The Germans are once again using an even
more perfected version of new tactics
and new artillery methods,
you know,
as we said before,
what you're quickly watching occur in
the four years of the first world war as
you're watching these armies transform
from something more like you know,
the Franco Prussian war in the 18
seventies to something more like the
Second World War and you can see it as
the tactics develop year after year from
stupidly walking into machine gun fire
and ordered rows of men to wear
infiltration.
Tactics are taking over and you're
beginning to see a lot of the same
methods being employed by these armies
for the very first time that every army
in the world still uses today involving
fire and movement and mutual support and
bypassing strong points.
When the Germans do this to the poor,
Italians and the Italians get,
I mean 300,000
people surrender.
That's how bad it is and yet the
Italians are able to move like 60 miles
back.
Reform their lines keep from falling
apart.
Totally.
In a way it help for the British and the
French.
You have to take troops again from the
western front to bolster this other
area,
but what it means is by the end of 1917,
the Germans have knocked out a bunch of
their opponents in this war.
When you look at how they started the
war with all these enemies against them,
look at what they've done in 1915,
they knock out Serbia in 1916,
they knock out Romania in 1917.
They've just knocked out Russia from the
war and given Italy such a bloody lip
that nothing is going to happen down
there for awhile and now in early 1918
for the first time in the war,
the Germans face the British and the
French without a whole lot of
distractions.
They don't have the Russians on the
other side and they have a small window
of opportunity before millions of
Americans started arriving in Europe to
swamp them.
This is the way Winston Churchill
describes the situation,
the setup we'll say,
and then I'm going to contrast that with
the way adults Hitler does and remember
that both of these people are writing to
specific audiences.
Churchill's writing to people who are in
the,
especially British and American
audiences and really,
you know,
a super patriotic,
romantic sort of an approach.
Hitler is writing this material for a
bunch of bitter war veterans who still
ache over what they experienced and and
this feeling of betrayal and the
bitterness since the war ended,
so they have different audiences they're
writing for,
but contrasting their styles and the way
they set this up is intriguing.
Here's how Churchill describes the
situation and remember and remember the
end of 1917,
the British are still in shock from the
battle that they still call passion.
Dale Churchill
says,
quote,
as the passion Dale struggled,
died away in the storms and mud of
winter.
The military rulers of Germany address
themselves to a new situation.
The collapse of Russia had enabled them
to transport a million men and 3000 guns
from the eastern to the western front
for the first time.
Therefore,
since the invasion,
they found themselves possessed of a
definite superiority over the allies in
France,
but the superiority was fleeting.
The United States had declared war and
was arming,
but had not yet arrived.
Once the great masses of American
manhood could be trained,
equipped,
transported,
and brought into the line of battle,
all the numerical advantage Germany had
gained from the destruction of Russia
would be more than counterbalanced.
At the same time,
the German main headquarters,
new the grave losses the British army
had suffered at Passchendaele and felt
themselves entitled to count upon a
marked decline in its strength and
fighting quality.
Lastly,
the amazing character of the German
Austrian victory over the Italians at
corporate reddough glittered temptingly
end quote.
He then goes on to say it would have
been a great time for the Germans to
open negotiations with us.
Instead,
they chose to attack
and before we get to Hitler's view of
the situation,
it's worth asking,
you know,
what were the Germans fighting for?
What did they hope to achieve?
What was the best case scenario in any
sort of end to the war?
And this is another difference between
the first and the second world wars in
the Second World War.
As soon as the Americans had said that
unconditional surrender,
it was supposed to be the victory
conditions,
it made the war.
One of those conflicts where you're
going to get what's called a
carthaginian piece,
you know,
reminiscent of how the Romans in the
third punic wars treated the city of
Carthage,
total destruction,
right?
The total occupation,
total submission and domination,
unconditional surrender are the piece
turns and the first world war,
like so much of the stuff that went on
during this time period,
the surrender was going to everyone
presumed going to be some sort of a
negotiated a.
it's going to be a bargaining session
and both sides are fighting to be the
superior person at the bargaining table,
right?
The one who can insist on better terms
as general Ludendorff,
the German military leader points out
what they're fighting for and why they
have to keep attacking.
He quote,
Germany could only make the enemy
inclined to piece by fighting.
It was first of all necessary to shake
the position of Lloyd George and Clemen,
so by a military victory before that was
done.
Piece was not to be thought of.
End Quote.
Now let's remember.
What ludendorff means is that he needs
this military victory to get the kind of
peace he wants.
Write a piece that,
for example,
gives Germany either director or de
facto control of places like Belgium for
example.
That's his bargaining position in any
sort of agreement that ends the war.
That's what they're fighting for and the
other side is too,
although more and more one of the
conditions that the Americans and the
British and the French are insisting on
is that the German form of government
has to change.
They can't be a monarchy anymore.
Well that may leave Germany still alive,
but it means if you are the emperor of
Germany or any of these high ranking
people that are a part of the German
monarchy,
it might as well be total war against
you.
Germany may live on,
but you're not going to be a part of it.
Out of Hitler is a soldier in the first
world war,
as we had mentioned earlier in his book,
Mine Comp,
which is written for this German veteran
audience and postwar audience that we
mentioned a little earlier.
He talks about the sculptures and the
sugars and all these people that are
beginning to sort of stab the German
army in the back.
From the home front,
that's the way it's portrayed and when
you read lewd doors,
a memoirs to written during a similar
time period,
he has the same thing going where you
know the reason that the German troops
are in danger is not because the enemy
will hurt them because they're sort of
this victorious entity on the
battlefield and it's because the home
front,
we'll let them down.
And before you know Hitler's sums up the
situation that we're facing right here
at the beginning of 1918,
he goes off on some strikes that are
taking place during this time period in
Germany.
There's a naval strike that happens in
1917.
That's disconcerting.
And then several hundred thousand
munitions workers go on strike right at
the beginning of the new year in 1918.
And,
and again,
when the German government punishes the
ringleaders of the strikes,
they send them to the front as
punishment,
but that means that they're infiltrating
now these military units and they're
infiltrating them with these ideas that
Luton Dorff and Hitler Tie right to
Bolshevism.
And Hitler ties Bolshevism by the way,
the Jews.
So right there you begin to see the
origins of the stab in the back theory,
right,
and here's the way Hitler in his,
in his.
Well,
what are you going to say?
Bestselling book,
Mine comp describes the situation the
Germans found themselves in after they'd
given the Italians the bloody nose at
corporate rental,
after they've knocked all these other
people out of the war and after finding
out you know that they're going to
attack
quote
toward the end of 1917,
the low point of the army's seems to
have passed.
The whole army took fresh hope and fresh
courage.
After the Russian collapse,
the conviction that the war would end
with the victory of Germany after all
began to seize the troops more and more
again,
singing could be heard and the calamity
Jane's became rarer again,
people believed in the future of the
father land and the quote,
the calamity Jane are these sculptures
and shirkers and people who say anti
patriotic things or or negative things
about the war effort.
He says,
quote,
especially the Italian collapse of
autumn,
1917 had had the most wonderful effect
in this victory.
We saw proof of the possibility of
breaking through the front even aside
from the Russian theater of war,
a glorious faith float again into the
hearts of the millions,
enabled them to await spring 19,
18 with relief and confidence.
The photo was visibly depressed in this
winter.
He remained quieter than usual.
This was the lull before the storm and
quote
than Hitler sums up his view of this
moment and what the allies were facing
now with a sort of Germany unleashed.
He says,
quote in the winter of 1917 to 1918,
dark clouds appeared for the first time
in the firmament of the allied world for
nearly four years.
They had been assailing the German
warrior,
and had been unable to encompass his
downfall and all this.
While the German had only his shield arm
free for defense.
While the sword was obliged to strike
now in the east,
now in the south,
but now at last,
the giants back was free.
Streams of blood had flown before he
administered final defeat to one of his
foes.
Now in the West.
He Shield was going to be joined by his
sword.
Up until then,
the enemy had been unable to break his
defense and now he himself was facing
attack.
The enemy feared him and trembled for
their victory and the quote
no,
in one sense,
this is a post first world war,
Hitler putting a rosy picture on this
thing,
you know,
with peer we were going to defeat them
and then stabbed in the back by the Jews
and Bolsheviks.
Right?
But at the same time,
there's some truth to a couple of these
things.
One,
the Bolsheviks were having an influence
on Germany and that attempt by Ludin
Dorf to,
you know,
get rid of his next door neighbor in the
apartment complex by burning his
apartment down is beginning to change
Germany a little bit in Luton.
Dorf writes about this in his memoirs in
a way,
remember writing years later so we can
pretend to have hindsight.
He basically acts like he understood the
risk was dangerous.
He thought they could contain the
Bolshevik intellectual contagion,
but he knew that there was a chance it
wouldn't work out that way and there's
something to that in terms of why the
Germans were all of a sudden beginning
to start to show real cracks in the
facade of the home front and some of
these people,
it should be pointed out that a guy like
Luton door for Hitler,
things are Bolsheviks,
are probably more like Social Democrats,
you know,
mild socialists,
but to a guy like lewd Neidorf,
anyone who's thinking that the war might
have gone on too long or that Germany
instead of an emperor might do better
with a representative democracy or a
republic or something.
That to them is traitorous and radical,
so you might as well be a Bolshevik
nonetheless,
think about what these people are going
through.
Four years of war.
All these countries in a sense,
sacrificing their future with each
generation of youngsters that they call
up and throw into the mall and they're
sacrificing their past to.
They're cannibalizing their country's
historical in longterm assets.
We've quoted the English wife of a
German nobleman princess blue shirt.
Evelyn Belushi,
writing in her diary,
she told this story that is just
heartbreaking about,
you know,
the fact that the Germans don't have
enough ammunition anymore and they're
starting to go into the society and and
take things to meltdown.
One historian I read said that during
this period more than 10,000
church bells were melted down and
princess blueshift tells a story about
that.
She says,
quote,
there are other signs too pathetic in
their way of the increasing scarcity of
metal for everywhere the old church
bells and even the organ pipes are being
dragged from the churches and turned
into ammunition.
Wilson,
oh,
into the scarcity of oil.
The sanctuary lamp,
such a dear familiar sight in Catholic
churches may no longer shed it's tender
light before the tabernacle in a small
town near here.
A sad little ceremony took place the
other day.
The Ancient Church Bell,
which had rung the people from the
cradle to the grave for 300 years and
more was requisitioned by the military
authorities.
The grief felt by the inhabitants was so
great that they determined to do their
ancient friend all the honor they could
and after having performed the regular
funeral service for the debt over it,
a procession was formed,
headed by the priest in his vestments
and his acolytes,
swinging their incense and the
inhabitants following the bell,
which was covered with wreaths and
flowers and hand it over to the military
authorities under tiers and
protestations and quote.
I look at that story is kind of symbolic
of you know the greatness of old Europe
at the height and the high water marks
if its wealth and civilization and
hundreds of years of glorious past
behind them sort of girding the whole
society being ripped apart and thrown
into the mall and the furnace to provide
the implements that are needed to fight
the war that is destroying its high
place on the world stage.
This is a sort of tragic irony that
isn't confined to Germany.
By the way.
This is how Britain and France and
Russia and all these old line powers
kind of.
They're trapped in this conflict now
that is chewing up their wealth,
destabilizing the structures of their
society,
and once again,
taking the next class of draftees who
reach now,
18 years old and throwing them into the
meat grinder to think of the pressure on
these people who are commanding all
these armies on,
on both sides.
I mean Ludin door if you can't help but
think about this guy because he's the
one who gets to decide how you play
Germany's last card,
the central powers,
last card.
Think of the people that are counting on
him from a completely human experiment.
Imagine the stress and responsibility
that falls on this one guy shoulders
more than anyone else on that side.
Obviously he's got help and staffs and
you know other people to consultant what
have you,
but basically the number one person's
responsibility is his.
He's got to plan the biggest battle in
world history and the stakes are
everything.
Wow.
This is the biggest encounter between,
you know,
the cutting edge militaries of the world
that has ever happened and that's what
Ludendorff is planning and it's an
immensely complicated affair with with
details beyond belief
mean Luton.
Dorf will start moving troops from the
eastern front who had been fighting the
Russians on trains all the way over to
the west before the Russians even sign a
peace treaty.
By the spring of 1918,
he's moved a million German soldiers who
had been fighting the Russians over to
the West where they can now be used
against the French and the British,
the German army in the West.
Numbers over 3 million soldiers by
spring 1918 and Luton Dorf has a plan
that he's going to,
you know,
put into place that that involves
throwing multiple punches at the French
and the British like a five punch
combination and he's going to use about
a million soldiers to form the fist.
Michael named after St Michael is the
first of these punches,
but the entire affair will sometimes be
called the 1918 spring offensive.
The German soldiers referred to it.
Sometimes it's just a great battle in
France that shows you how big it's going
to be.
One part of it,
sometimes referred to as the peace
offensive,
and sometimes the entire affair is
called the Kaiser Schlock.
The emperor's battle.
Historians have been fascinated by these
series of battles ever since for a
couple of major reasons.
One is the scope and the other other
stakes.
This is the largest battle the world's
ever seen.
The complexity is unbelievable.
I mean it's very hard battle to follow
or explain or talk about it in the front
will be miles long.
It will involve millions of men.
The complexity in terms of trying to
plan and arrange and get ready for one
of these big offensives in five or six
months,
which is your planning window is perhaps
the most complex task human beings have
ever attempted to tackle.
I think you could say that there are
bigger things like trying to create a
global society,
which we're in the process of doing
right now.
That's very hard,
but you can do that over time and build
on the achievements of previous
generations and sort of evolve towards a
solution to a complex problem.
These people have a time window and it's
short.
Get the Kaiser schlock done within five
months.
Boom's got to be ready on the 21st of
March.
Boom.
Get it done.
I mean just the attempts to keep the
allies in the dark about where it's
coming are complex as heck.
I mean,
they will move troops and equipment at
night.
They will cover up the artillery gun
wheels with cloth so you can't hear
them.
They will roused out the civilian
population and all these towns and March
them around in all directions to
confuse,
you know,
allied observers,
they will scramble and use false radio
messages and just because you know,
this is sort of a transition period in
history just to cover all their bases.
They will also pull out the carrier
pigeons,
including carrier pigeons,
captured from the other side,
put false notes in the little
compartment,
you know,
in their leg and send them off.
That's called covering all your bases,
isn't it?
But think of the planning and complexity
and all the work that goes on.
The other fascinating aspect to
historians are the stakes.
When do you have stakes like this?
The biggest war and human history,
and as one historian put it,
Ludina door from the Germans have six
months to change the course of the war
here.
After that,
the numerical advantage the Americans
will provide will be overwhelming.
So you have this window of opportunity
and it's an all or nothing thing.
My southern historians have argued that
the Germans should have just gone on the
defensive here,
dug in and made the allied forces fight
until 1920 or 1921,
um,
before the mounting losses would force
them into some sort of a favorable
piece.
But that kind of ignores how bad things
are on the home front,
right?
Even if the German army can withstand
these allied attacks,
they're going to lose the people back at
home for a year past the infamous turnip
winter.
What happens when the turnip winter is
the good old days,
right?
Pollutant or from the Germans.
Don't just put this attack together.
They're excited about it.
The German troops are almost ecstatic.
The morale is sky high.
They want a chance to win the war.
This is why this first punch operation,
Michael,
is so important because this is the
punch where all the optimism is in
place,
right?
Everybody's drinking the Koolaid.
Luton Dorf decides to,
you know up his gamble ante a little bit
more.
Not only is he gambling with this
attack,
but he's going to,
you know,
essentially pull out the rocket fuel
from the great mass of he goes through
and calms his army for the best man,
right?
The healthiest and strongest that ones
are the highest morale.
The veterans who weren't cynical yet,
all these people who are better than the
rest of the herd and pulls them out and
puts them into special units and gives
them the best weapons.
Again,
pulled away from the great mass of
people and the special training,
what they called special training.
In the first world war today,
we would call standard training in a
modern military.
They called them storm trooper tactics.
We call them fire and move tactics,
and every army in the world uses them
now.
Nonetheless,
what Ludendorff has done here is create
an initial advantage,
you know,
for himself because his best troops are
going to go up against the great mass of
French and British troops that they run
into.
They will give out the lion's share of
casualties to the French and the British
and the allies,
but they will also take the lion's share
of casualties.
This is a gamble because when Ludin Dorf
uses these best troops,
he's going to use them up and if they
haven't won by that point,
he's going to be left with the not best
troops,
the leftovers people who've had their
best weapons stripped from them and
given to the other guys.
People who haven't been trained in the
latest tactics,
people who would expect it are going to
simply move up and occupied the trenches
that have already been conquered.
It's a Campbell and on March 21st.
It's not a gamble Ludina and has to
worry about because he's got all these
storm trooper and assault units.
You know,
waiting for the moment to jump off,
synchronizing their watches and waiting
for what will be the largest cannonade
in history to kickoff on March 21st
operation,
Michael begins the first punch of the
German multi punch combination aimed
primarily at the British.
Some 10,000
artillery pieces will open fire at about
dawn.
Somewhere in the 4:00
hour
they will only fire only it's forever.
If you're under fire,
they'll only fire for about four hours.
It's what's called a hurricane
bombardment.
Very different than what the allies were
doing through most of the war where they
will bombard for weeks on end sometimes
right at the Somme in 1916.
The big artillery battle,
they'll fire one point 7 million shells
in the first week and it's famous
because,
oh my gosh,
think of how many shells that is,
but every first world war major
offensive outdoes,
the earlier ones in,
in this one,
they fire,
you know,
becomes a contest like a statistic in
the Guinness Book of World Records,
but they fire one point,
1 million shells in four hours and it's
conducted like a symphony of death.
The Germans had brought in all of their
big,
I guess you could call the military
stars to this battle.
One of them is this artillery conductor,
Georg Brooke Miller,
I think his name,
but his nickname is breakthrough mueller
and he has a whole theory and that he's
been perfecting on how to use these
artillery barrages and part of his
theory involves the idea that you don't
need to destroy the enemy positions,
which is what it's always been done.
All you need to do is neutralize them
all you need to do with that machine gun
nest to stop them from shooting long
enough so that the infantry doesn't get
killed on the way to taking out the
machine gun nest themselves.
So he uses a lot more gas first of all,
and he has a whole order that all this
comes into me.
First.
He shoots the gas.
That doesn't kill you,
but it's like tear gas.
It makes you gag and vomit and it makes
you rip off your gas masks,
but then he hits you with the phosgene
gas that if you're not wearing your gas
mask kills you.
He'll also use mustard gas,
which is a long lasting,
so it's like spraying the the ant spray
that will still kill the ants a week
later,
even though it's dried up,
the mustard gas is shot at all these
important crossroads and areas and
heights and observation posts so that
either you get out or you're so covered
up and gas masks and everything,
you can hardly function and the Germans
just want you to be impeded,
right.
You just have to be not functioning long
enough for the waves of German soldiers
to be free and clear to overrun your
physicians.
It also has the added benefit of not
making the terrain in front of your
advancing troops look like the cratered
surface of the moon.
Large shell craters have become a
barrier all its own in previous battles.
In this one,
the German artillery was going to
minimize that.
Keep the way open for a quick and
shocking advance.
The artillery opens fire on March 21st.
You know,
it's strange to say that they're
surprised because everyone knew this was
coming,
but the surprises in the intensity and
the locations and whatnot,
the Kaiser,
the emperor of Germany and the face of
the German military,
Hindenburg or reportedly at the battle
and the Kaiser was known to have this
wooden tower that's sort of like a
ranger station erected so he could try
to see a battle,
which was something that in the 19th
century wouldn't have been that strange.
People came out with picnic baskets in
the first major battle of the US civil
war to watch and the Kaiser and
Hindenburg were supposedly at this
battle to watch it unfold.
Winston Churchill was also there when
the cannonade opened up and you get this
feeling that he's a [inaudible] figure
that he's just not gonna miss any big
historical event.
If he can avoid that.
And he was at this battle too and he
gives one of the original and much
quoted accounts of what it was like.
He said,
you know,
he was walking around and everyone was
waiting for something to happen and he
woke up from his sleep somewhere in the
4:00
hour and who's relatively silent,
and then boom quote.
Suddenly after what seemed about a half
an hour,
the silence was broken by six or seven
very loud and very heavy explosion.
Several miles away.
I thought they were are 12 inch guns,
but they were
probably mines and then exactly as a
pianist runs his hand across the
keyboard from treble to base their rows
and less than one minute.
The most tremendous cannonade I shall
ever here and quote.
He said that quote,
the weight and intensity of the
bombardment surpassed anything which
anyone had ever known before,
and to quote Ernst Junger,
the German soldier we've talked about
sometimes in the story is also at this
battle.
He's on the opposite side of the
shelling rights and not even the side
that's being shelled and he says that it
made every other event he'd been to in
this war,
looked like a tea party,
and he was at many of the big battles,
right?
A tea party.
He said that the shelling seemed to
suspend the laws of nature.
He said,
you know,
you couldn't light a match or anything
because the shock waves,
even as far away as the German troops
were,
would blow it right out.
He says that if you looked over to the
enemy lines I'll use saw is rolling
clouds of flame and it looked like the
way the desert looks when you look in
the distance and the heat is shimmering
and makes you almost see Mirages.
He said that that's what it looks like.
You know,
on the side of the people being shelled.
The effect on the British troops is
almost like being punched drunk.
A private in the first West Yorkshire
Regiment who was there explained it this
way,
quote,
nobody could stand more than three hours
of sustained shelling before they
started feeling sleepy and numb.
You're hammered after three hours and
you're there for the picking.
When he comes over,
it's a bit like being under an
anesthetic.
You can't put a lot of resistance up on
the other fronts I'd been on.
There had been so much of our resistance
that whenever Jerry opened up,
our artillery opened up and quieted him
down,
but there was no retaliation.
This time he had a free do at us and to
quote,
I should point out that the Germans
called the British Tommy and the British
called the Germans Jerry often,
so that's how that happens.
Historian Alexander Watson quotes a
German battalion,
Dr Ernst determine who recorded that men
reacted to shelling quote for the most
part with the feeling of enormous
sleepiness and quote,
and then said that you get both
emotional and physical changes in men
who are being shelled.
So think about the people on the
receiving end of what's about to be a
ground attack after they've experienced
something that does this to them,
Witterman says,
quote,
the eyes pop out of their sockets.
The expression becomes fixed and glassy.
The facial skin loses all of its red
color.
The skin becomes yellow,
the cheekbones protrude.
The lifts are shut tight and sticky,
spittle tax up the tongue to the roof of
the mouth.
The heart works in short convulsive
beats.
Breathing becomes slower from time to
time.
A cold shutter runs through the body and
the teeth chatter,
every spoken word is felt as agony and
quote Watson goes to point out that
surveys had shown that the troops were
particularly scared of artillery and
unsettled by it.
He writes,
quote,
not only did artillery cause more
casualties than any other weapon on the
western front,
but those injuries that it did inflict.
We're often grievous.
Contemporary psychiatrist agreed that
men's primary fear was not death,
but mutilation wounds to the stomach,
jaw and dyes were particularly dreaded.
It is that significant that artillery
fire was more likely than any other
weapon to cause head wounds.
Moreover,
shells were terrifying because as
lieutenants,
st lagers,
somewhat coyly observed,
they could make such a mess of one and
quote,
Watson continues quote,
the weapon eviscerated,
maimed,
and disfigured body parts could be
scattered over wide distances and legs
and arms blown into trees by the force
of explosions.
Such sites were obviously extremely
disturbing,
especially when the victims were friends
or comrades.
As lieutenant boxall remarked quote,
when you have seen a shell fall into the
midst of six men and packed three of
them away in a sandbag,
one wonders whether anything matters and
to quote
this is when you realize though that
these people are veterans in this combat
and that this makes a huge difference.
These people have been hardened to their
current state by degrees,
by seeing many horrible things in the
past and living through situations that
while they might not be as extreme as
what they're about to go through,
our smaller versions on the way there,
it's like lifting a smaller amount of
weight on your way up to lifting a
greater amount of weight.
It's not like taking a week civilian
like yours truly and throwing him into
the Kaiser sherlocked tomorrow and then
expecting him to endure under shell
fire.
And while there are certainly people
that fell apart under shell fire,
broken,
ran under shall fire lost their minds.
You know,
to shell shock.
I mean a lot of those kinds of things.
The the amazing story here,
and I think this is what has amazed
people throughout history since it
happened,
is that the vast,
vast,
vast majority of people stayed there in
those positions and took it.
Having the logical part of their brain
and self control somehow overriding
their animal instincts that must have
been screaming at them to simply flea.
But as I said,
these people had been hardened by what
they'd seen before.
You know,
the very day before March,
20,
first before this artillery barrage
happens.
Ernst Junger is in a shell hole in a
relatively safe part of the line.
He and an officer are in one and a whole
bunch of manner in the big shell hole
next to his.
It's like an amphitheater he says,
and they're
sort of having a meeting.
Everybody's stack their weapons and it's
calm and they're shell fire going on and
then all of a sudden sort of a random
stray shell falls into that big crater
that's built like an amphitheater that
had 100 men in it.
It's maybe the most gruesome upsetting
part of youngers,
gruesome and upsetting story.
And he says after the explosion,
it's so freaked him out.
And this is Ernst Junger,
we don't.
One of the,
one of the Veterans Veterans,
he goes tearing off running in a sort of
a panic before.
Eventually he'll stop himself and
realizes he should go back and try to
help some of those men.
But then that same orange junger,
you know,
that next morning,
whatever it is,
12,
15 hours afterwards is going to be
sitting in his jumping off point,
synchronizing his watch,
watching this artillery drop on the
British and getting ready to go over the
top and attack.
What's amazing is when he does so he
does so in an almost giddy fashion.
It's hard to describe the,
the mood that these soldiers going over
the top,
you know,
suggest during this battle.
I mean,
ernst young or is not necessarily
representative,
but he says everybody else,
we're sort of kind of on the edge of
sanity,
almost busy work.
But at the same time he says that they
would talk to each other and it would
only come out in little fragments of
sentences.
And he said,
anybody who was observing us would think
we were incredibly happy
and at the same time he's talking about
this rage that's coming over him and he
squeezes his eyes and the tears are
coming out and he's ready to hurt
somebody.
And what's funny when you read it is it
kind of reminds you something that may
be in the back of your head you knew
already.
But I think when we look at these modern
soldiers coming from Nice backgrounds
like ourselves and you know,
well trained and educated and all these
kinds of things,
we somehow assume that the very
tendencies that we will freely admit
that ancient peoples had and vikings hat
and all these kinds of peoples that
could get up into a busy work rage,
you know,
and kill a victim and stand up and
celebrate in it and enjoy being a
warrior.
That somehow because we have aircraft
and artillery machine guns and a nice.
I mean that it's all gone.
And in some people it is.
But in some people it's not.
And Ernst Junger goes looking for
someone to kill when he jumps out of
these.
Jumping off points after the artillery
barrage lifts in the German Army,
attacks on March 21st,
the big sweep at Operation Michael.
It's foggy by the way.
This will be one of the things that Luke
Dorf will get lucky with a couple of
times in his multi punch combination.
Fog is not great for the German
attackers.
It makes it difficult,
but it's a nightmare for the defenders.
The Germans are using what are sometimes
called infiltration tactics and if it's
foggy infiltration tactics are a lot
more effective.
The British have setup all these defense
zones with crossing machine,
gun fire and all these things were all
these,
all these different defense readouts can
help each other,
but because of the they can't see
anything and then all of a sudden the
Germans are jumping into the trenches
where the British soldiers are.
You catching them totally off guard
historian Peter Harte quotes Captain
Charles Miller,
who was on the line as the German's
approach for their initial attack.
You know,
before 9:00
AM on the morning of the 21st through
the fog and says quote.
The first attackers were into the trench
long before the [inaudible] lifted.
I was so occupied with the flanks that I
barely saw them before.
They appeared out of the mist and leapt
down into the trench in a moment.
We were all mixed up in hand to hand
fighting.
I had two men coming at me with their
bayonets,
one of whom I think I shot with my
revolver while a sergeant standing just
behind me,
shot the other at point blank range with
his rifle barrel over my shoulder,
but almost at the same second,
a German stick bomb came whistling into
the trench from the parapet right into
the bunch of us and killed or wounded
practically the whole lot of us,
English and German alike.
Whether it was actually this bomb or a
bayonet stabbed that gave me the wound
in my neck.
I don't know.
It might've been either
for a moment.
We were clear,
but there was a nasty little shambles
around us.
Sergeant Ad Cock,
who had just saved my life.
Having his head blown off,
I felt awfully weak and discovered that
a river of blood was flowing from my
neck.
I tried to bandage it,
but the bandage wouldn't hold before
they attacked us again.
They brought up some trench mortars and
knocked seven bells out of us than
swarmed into the trench.
By that time,
there were only a handful of us left on
our feet and all I suppose wounded.
I got another wound from a stick bomb
which put a bit of metal into my thigh
before I collapsed.
I tried to give the surrender signal and
hoped I succeeded thereby in saving a
few lives.
We had done our best and to quote,
and one of the things that happens with
these modern battles is that they really
turn into hundreds of smaller encounters
that when you add them up together equal
this big thing going on over 40 miles.
But when you read the accounts of these
battles,
they all sound like,
you know,
me and 10 guys took that machine gun
nest 100 yards away and it took us three
hours and we lost two men and we killed
everybody in the machine gun nest.
And then we continued to move on.
That's an encounter in this war,
right?
So every time you read one,
it sounds like an isolated little
incident.
In fact,
younger when he comes upon the first
enemy soldier,
he sees on March 21st it's this private
encounter,
this moment where youngers in this
almost buzzard mood that he just talked
about,
Giddy,
they'd been drinking alcohol there,
punch drunk from all the artillery.
I mean,
it's just a sensory overload and he sees
this enemy and he says,
quote.
Then I saw my first enemy,
a figure in Brown,
uniform wounded,
apparently crouched 20 paces away in the
middle of the battered path with his
hands propped on the ground.
I turned a corner and we caught sight of
each other.
I saw him jump
as I approached and stare at me with
gaping eyes while I,
with my face behind my pistol,
stocked up to him slowly and coldly.
A bloody scene with no witnesses was
about to happen.
It was a relief to me.
Finally to have the photo in front of me
and within reach,
I set the mouth of the pistol at the
man's temple.
He was too frightened to move while my
other fist grabbed hold of his tunic,
feeling metals and badges of rank and
officer.
He must have held some command post in
these trenches with the plaintiff's
sound.
He reached into his pocket not to pull
out a weapon,
but a photograph which he held up to me.
I saw him on it,
surrounded by numerous family all
standing on a terrorist.
It was a plea from another world.
Later,
I thought it was blind chance that I let
him go and plunged onward.
That one man of all often appeared in my
dreams.
I hope that meant he got to see his
homeland again and to quote
so even in the blind rage of the
busywork moment that younger had
described earlier,
he was able to pull himself from the
brink and answer that plea from another
world and let that soldier live.
Mercy could be a dangerous commodity on
a battlefield like this.
It was very normal for soldiers going
past something like a bunker that might
have enemy troops in it to just simply
throw grenades down the stairs into the
bunker and not worry about it.
And just keep on moving.
There were also a killings in hot blood
a lot of the time it was normal.
For example,
if troops kept firing at you all the way
up until you were almost on top of them
and then tried to surrender,
good luck with that.
There was killing in cold blood too on
all sides,
but by and large when they could both
sides like to take prisoners.
None of these armies surrendered in
large numbers though was quite unusual,
but a mark of what a great first day
operation Michael has is that it sees a
huge amount of British troops
surrendering in numbers that you never
see.
Twenty 1000 of them on the first day.
17,000
of these people had been casualties due
to that for our initial bombardment so
you can see how their nerves are shot in
some cases
that they are infected by all those
physical symptoms that we called it
earlier and that they're just stunned.
Historian John Keegan tells a story of a
British machine gunner who must've been
pretty representative of this day,
who is mowing down German soldiers like
Ernst Junger as they approach his
machine gun position and Keegan quotes
the soldier as saying quote.
I thought we'd stopped them when I felt
a bump in the back.
I turned around and there was a German
officer with a revolver in my back.
Come along,
Tommy,
you've done enough.
I turned round and then said,
thank you very much,
sir.
I know what I would've done if I had
been held up by a machine gunner and had
that revolver in my hand.
I had a finished him off.
He must have been a real gentleman.
It was 20 past 10.
I know to the minute because I looked at
my watch end quote and if you actually
had to surrender to Germans,
you know while this offensive was going
on,
it could be a very near run thing.
British private Alfred Gross is captured
on the 22nd of March,
so the next day with a boy as he
described him,
but a soldier nonetheless who's badly
hit in the head and he's bleeding and
gross writes,
quote the area we cross swept by rifle
and machine gun fire.
We crawl an escape it.
The boy is in pain and crying presently.
He jumps up.
Here they come,
he cries.
I pull him down.
Who?
I asked Jerry,
he said,
I look cautiously up there.
He is right enough.
The first wave almost on top of us,
and quote grouches account continues.
Quote,
leave it to me.
Boy,
we're done.
We're prisoners now.
Do whatever I tell you.
I wait a second and then up I say,
and take your helmet off.
We do.
So the German in front of me says,
ah,
raises his rifle and takes aim.
I muttered to myself.
I hope to God he won't pull that trigger
for 10 seconds.
We remain.
So then he lowers his rifle and says
what I take to be wounded.
I nod and say,
yes,
yes.
He beckons and we approach.
We still have our equipment.
Dawn and the Germans,
other shouts pointing to it,
slip it off.
I cried at the boy doing it myself.
The German has spared us.
Would we have spared him under the
circumstances God knows,
perhaps not and to quote,
but that same sort of gallantry you see
on the German side in cases like this is
present on the French side and the
British side and the Russian side.
I mean this is.
This is a human element coming forth in
the midst of all this evil and of course
just as something to juxtaposition the
whole thing.
You see the killing of prisoners by all
sides as well.
Ian Passingham calls March 21st the day
of the opening of the Michael Offensive,
the first punch in the multi punch
combination,
right?
That the Germans are going to throw one
of the most dramatic days of the whole
war and he says,
quote in the event,
and despite numerous tales of heroic
last stands and daring do the 21st of
March was a disastrous day for Hague's.
B,
e,
f meaning the British forces.
It was the bloodiest day of the first
world war.
There were over 78,000
casualties,
almost 40,000
on each side though the storm troops had
advanced in one or two places up to 10
miles by the end of the day in the
south.
Overall 20,
first of March was a day of great
sacrifice and confusion and quote 78,000
casualties in one day.
That's your new world's record
right there.
The horrible battle of Waterloo,
100 years previously had seen maybe
60,000
casualties on the first day,
but there was no second day at the
battle of Waterloo operation.
Michael led to 78,000
casualties on the first day of the first
punch of a multi punch combination that
would go on for months.
Randall Gray,
who wrote a piece on the Kaiser Slot
said it was quote the greatest and most
intense battle ever fought by the
British army and quote.
He also said,
quote,
it certainly represented the most awful
non-nuclear,
but chemical fighting or deal undergone
by 20th century soldiers with the
possible exception of some 1941,
1945 eastern front battles and the Iran
Iraq war and the quote.
I always try to remind myself that what
these soldiers went through with these
battles,
scarred them forever and and and you
know there's a difference.
We should understand that.
That there are a lot of people who go to
war who never see any combat,
who,
who deal with paperwork or logistics or
supply and they're all very important,
but the people who come home after this
war and change the psyche of the world,
the writers,
the thinkers,
just just the everyday people whose
attitudes have been shocked into a
different paradigm by what the
experience in this combat go through
things that have to haunt them.
I was particularly moved in one of these
kaiser shocked battles.
A German soldier under artillery barrage
talks about what happened to him and
when you think about him having to live
with this memory the rest of his life
and how it altered him on a personal
level,
and then imagine millions of people who
had seen equally scarring events in
their lives who went on to help create
this postwar world.
And you can see how this war dug deeply
into the psyche of 20th century
civilization and gouged out a permanent
wound.
The soldiers under French artillery fire
in one of these battles.
And he writes,
quote,
French shells,
began to hit to the right and left of us
leaving human forms writhing in agony.
Our advanced came to a stop and after
hesitating a few minutes,
we drew back.
While the artillery fire followed us,
ripping large gashes in our formation.
Soon the French drum firing Gulf dust.
The air was filled with gas and flying
pieces of steel.
We automatically mounted the machine gun
for action.
And then like animals,
we burrowed into the earth as if trying
to find protection deepen its bosom.
Something struck my back where I carried
my gas mask,
but I did not pay attention to it.
A steel splinter broke the handle of my
spade and another knocked the remains
out of my hand.
I kept digging with my bare hands,
ducking my head.
Every time a shell exploded nearby,
a boy to my side hit in the arm and
cried out for help.
I crawled over to him,
rip the sleeves of his coat and shirt
open and started to bind the bleeding
part.
The gas was now so thick that I could
hardly discern what I was doing.
My eyes began to water and I felt as if
I would choke.
I reached for my gas mask,
pulling it out of its container and then
notice to my horror that a splinter had
gone through it,
leaving a large hole.
I had seen death thousands of times,
stared it in the face,
but never experienced the fear I felt.
Then immediately I reverted to the
primitive.
I felt like an animal cornered by
hunters with the instinct of self
preservation upper most.
My eyes fell on the boy who's armed.
I had bandaged.
Somehow he'd managed to put the gas mask
on his face with his one good arm.
I leapt at him and in the next moment
had ripped the gas masks from his face
with a feeble gesture.
He tried to wrench it from my grasp.
Then fell back exhausted.
The last thing I saw before putting on
the mask where his pleading eyes and to
quote
that's related in Peter Hearts,
wonderful book,
the Great War.
He has such a way of finding those
incidents that when you read about them,
they they boggle your mind and then you
can go forget about them,
but imagine the guy who has to live with
that the rest of his life.
Those kinds of moments that the extremes
of human experience where these moral
choices are thrust in your face like the
Ernst Young,
or do I shoot this guy before he shows
me the picture of his family.
It's kind of what makes these wars
fascinating is how do people behave when
they are under this kind of intense
pressure and strange extreme
circumstances.
This is what's happening at the ground
level.
At the big picture level.
This last card played by the Germans
here has been shockingly effective.
The British fifth army,
which let's be honest,
was in no position to be taking on a
German force like this at the moment.
They had been recovering from a previous
battle.
They were holding too large a part of
the front.
They had infrastructure and defenses
that needed some work and then they get
hit with this force in this,
in this violence,
and it immediately shoves them
backwards.
The Germans penetrate the first line of
their defenses in an hour or two.
They're into the second line of their
defenses by lunchtime.
This causes the first of several of what
I call soil your underpants moments that
are part of the Kaiser Schlock,
the multi punch combination of Luton
doors.
By the second day of the battle
historian hold your irving says that the
fighting is intense.
It's hand to hand,
it's it's close combat with grenades and
it's,
it's brutal,
and he writes,
quote,
after two days,
ludendorff mobile and attack divisions
had decimated golf's fifth army and
driven the British almost 40 miles
behind the song and the croisette canal.
Haig had lost 200,000
killed and wounded,
90,000
prisoners of war and 1300 guns.
Most importantly,
his defenses had been ruptured.
A 50 mile gap driven through his lines.
Open field,
lay ahead of the Germans and quote,
this initial advance has morale
skyrocketing amongst the Kaiser and some
around him pulled your says,
quote
wilhelm.
The second rushed,
congratulations to the troops and
admonish them to push on.
This is the kaiser talking.
Now quote,
much has been accomplished,
much more.
Still remains to be conquered and quote
her vague continues.
Quote,
the Kaiser ordered schools closed in
Germany to mark the victory in quotes.
He presented Hindenburg with the Iron
Cross with golden rays last given to
prince blue shirt for reducing pressure
of Napoleon and wilhelm.
The second informed his entourage over
champagne.
That quote,
if an English delegation came to sue for
peace,
it must kneel before the German standard
for it was a question here of a victory
of the monarchy over democracy and quote
glutened door for sure at his kaiser
that the British army had been defeated
and the quote,
but many in the upper echelons of
Germany's military were much more sober
about what was happening here and
realize that at the pace they were
getting chewed up,
it was going to be a problem.
The question is,
who was going to break first?
This is like this boxing match,
which we've compared this entire war to
throughout this entire series.
We have two exhausted fighters here in
the German high command is kind of
thinking,
you know,
we really don't have that much left and
then some of the German high command or
countering with.
Yeah,
but neither do they.
The fifth army will be forced to pull
back when they pull back.
The army next to them has to pull back
the third army.
Otherwise they'll lose contact with each
other.
The problem is is that both these armies
are attached to a French army and this
is the first crisis that erupts.
There's a breach about to open up
between the British and the French
armies.
Splitting those armies would be huge.
This brings us to what the heck is Luke
Dorf trying to do?
Right?
What's his plan here in this?
Kaiser sherlocked?
Well,
it's one of the big controversies of the
war.
Theoretically he wants to punch a hole
in the line,
surround the British,
push the British up like a bunch of
falling dominoes all the way back up to
the English Channel,
thereby changing the entire complexion
of the war,
but he's flexible.
He has this saying that has often been
quoted afterwards because this is one of
the things ludendorff gets the most
critiqued about where he says in terms
of the strategy and tactics for this big
multi punch combination quote,
we will punch hole and
then we will see.
We did it that way in Russia and the
court and he and Hindenburg did kind of
do that when they were commanding the
eastern front.
They go in there,
they'd punch a hole,
they'd roll up a Russian army,
do a bazillion casualties,
and you do that long enough and
eventually a rickety Russian state falls
apart.
But this is France and Britain.
Are you really sort of gambling that
you're going to open up this whole and
they're just going to fall apart?
Well alluded doors.
Attitude is that I'm not going to fall
for the mistakes of my predecessors.
Those people who you know have this one
place they want to attack and they run
into a brick wall and they just keep
throwing more troops into the meat
grinder in front of that brick wall.
We're not going to do that when we break
through somewhere.
We're going to reinforce success and
this is supposed to be part of the
latest German ideas about the war,
but what happens if the breakthrough
comes at a spot where there's not that
much of war,
winning quality,
you know,
goals anywhere nearby because the bulge,
some even call it a breakthrough that
the Germans have against the British.
Fifth Army happens at a place where
there's not anything close by that's
going to win you the war.
All those places had been,
you know,
extra specially defended by the best
troops in the best defense is the reason
that the Germans breakthrough here is
because there wasn't some very important
object nearby,
but the Germans are moving so far that
eventually they run into one a place
where the roads and railways all come
together.
A French city name I'm.
Yeah,
and it's at this point that something
that's been an issue for the entire war
comes to a,
an almost fatal head,
and that is the fact that there is no
coordinated allied leadership at all
because at this point,
Douglas Haig,
the British military commander on the
scene would like help from the French.
In this crisis situation,
please send me troops and historians
have argued about whether or not they
did.
Some historians nowadays say they not
only did they did it before they were
even asked,
and they did it in larger numbers.
They were British historians that have
always said the French were very stingy
with extra troops and put Hagen,
a situation where the worst possible
thing could happen.
I mean the soil,
your underpants moment indeed,
but Haig was asking for troops from a
guy named Pataki who had his own
worried.
He was worried he'd gotten an
intelligence that the Germans had
another fist that was poised to attack
near Paris,
and as far as potassium was concerned,
that was his number one concern.
There's a meeting on March 26th and some
historians have described Hague's mood
at this point as near panic as he runs
up against this brick wall where he's
not getting the kind of help he feels
like he needs and he's in a crisis
situation.
Eric Dorn grows,
says quote gaps also opened between the
British and the French.
Across the EU is river sending.
Hey Gunton near panic as he ordered
trenches dug to protect the channel.
Ports shifted six divisions from his
northern armies,
including three from the front line and
implored pitocin to rush 20 divisions.
Now he's quoting the head of the general
staff.
The British general staffs,
Sir Henry Wilson Quote,
Hague is cowed,
said Wilson on March 25th quote.
He said that unless the whole of the
French army came up,
we were beaten and it would be better to
make peace on any terms we could and the
seriousness of this situation finally
leads the allied Entente powers to
disregard questions of sovereignty and
jealous guarding of have rights and
privileges and all that,
and finally decide to nominate and
finally approved somebody whose job it's
going to be not so much to be the boss,
but to be the guy that coordinates,
and this honor goes to the French
military leader,
Ferdinand Foshan.
We had talked about him in an earlier
episode.
Very aggressive,
energetic,
brave.
I'm one of the first things he'll do is
issue an order that says that there will
be no retreat from this important French
city that Ludendorff is going to go
after.
Now I'm,
yeah,
that people have to die where they stand
basically not one step back and he will
dole out the reinforcements as he sees
fit,
but he's going to be very stingy and the
generals like Haig will think that he's
stingy.
Lloyd George,
the British Prime Minister,
writes in his memoir as though that that
Fascia was being a gambler and that's
what generals often have to be.
How often have we said that dwarfs
gambler,
but would fatia is gambling on is that
he can be stingy with these reserves and
that these generals can manage without
them or manage without what they really
want.
I Mean Hague's upset.
He can't get 20 divisions.
20 divisions is a huge force.
No wonder you can't get 20 division.
Fatia is trying to safeguard and
stockpile a reserve force.
People that could just stay back,
stay in good health,
ready to go,
chomping at the bit,
and then unleash a counter attack.
When the German offensive is like the
wave that washes up on the beach and
loses its momentum right before it sinks
back into the surf,
that's when you want to launch a counter
offensive with fresh troops.
When the enemy's exhausted,
what Foshe sees in this multiplex hunch
combination of Luton do offices an
opportunity to win the war.
Let the Germans punch themselves out
here and then take it to them with a
fresh force.
Once they're exhausted,
but that fresh force can only be built
by being stingy with reserves when
people like Hagar worried that he's
about to be pushed into the sea and the
French and the British were about to
lose contact and the,
you know,
middle,
middle part of this front,
there is desperate,
you know,
heroic.
When you talk about some of the fighting
of this battle,
it's the Kinda thing where,
you know,
you have the last four guys with the gun
overrun fighting to the last man to give
the rest of the army,
you know,
another hour of safety while they,
move back to reserve positions.
I mean it's,
it's really frantic heroic stuff and the
Germans are striving.
They know this is the war winning or war
losing moment and they're giving it.
Their,
all in the casualties are outrageous.
A lot of people talk about this time
period as the end of trench warfare in
the beginning of open warfare again,
which hasn't existed on the western
front since the war started.
I mean you had like six months of it and
the casualties were terrible.
And then everything went down
underground and into the trenches
because it was the only way to stay
alive with all that lead flying up
above,
you know,
ground level.
And now we've had reverted to open
warfare again in the troop.
Seemed happy to be moving,
but this is also much more dangerous
because those trenches,
we're there for a reason.
They protected you from the kinds of
casualties that you're starting to see
right here at Kaiser Schlock with the
resumption of open warfare.
Again comes the kind of casualties that
we hadn't seen for awhile.
Something happens on March 23rd that
it's,
it's hard to put it in a proper context.
What happens is people in Paris start
seeing and hearing explosions out of
nowhere,
decent size explosions to and in an
interesting sort of twist.
The explosion comes with no sound of any
shell or anything.
There's just nothing.
And then boom,
you know,
something goes up in smoke
and it's puzzling for awhile.
The people in Paris can't figure out
what's going on.
And they were,
you know,
there are books that talk about this
where people will be in cafes,
speculating on what's causing the
explosions and you know,
aircraft is what everybody was thinking,
but the skies were clear and there were
no aircraft.
And then one of the theories floated by
some of these people in cafes that were
quoted was that the Germans had somehow
smuggled in artillery piece,
you know,
secretly hiding it in some forest or
something within range of Paris because
he was so obviously an artillery piece
or a bomb.
Finally,
what the French will figure out is that
they are being shelled from a cannon
firing from the German side of the line,
but the German side of the line is way
farther than the range of any other gun
that anyone's ever heard of.
It turns out that Paris is not being
shelled by one gun,
but probably multiple guns,
but they're called the Paris gun and
they're being shelled from a distance of
75 miles.
The gun can reportedly shoot 81 miles.
And to give you an idea of how long that
is,
one of the longer range guns you will
ever run into,
or the 16 inch guns on the American Iowa
class battleships and they can shoot,
if I recall correctly,
between 25 and 30 miles.
So you're talking about a gun that
shoots twice as far easily.
It's got a barrel that is a hundred feet
long.
They have to have a special crane like
device that,
that,
that sits over the gun and holds the
barrel up and keeps it from drooping.
The shell that it shoots,
I am told is the thing that humans ever
launched into the stratosphere and the
distances were so long that the gunners
had to reportedly account for the
rotation of the earth in their
calculations.
But their calculations couldn't be that
targeted.
I mean these people could only shoot it
cities and that accounts for why the
shell sort of landed randomly.
The worst occasion is a is a much talked
about still incident during a holiday
when people were in church and one of
these shells came crashing through the
roof,
exploded in the church and killed like
80 or 90 people.
It was awful,
but over the course of the conflict,
it would only dish out a little more
than 800 casualties in less than 300
deaths,
which you know isn't wonderful,
but if you have a giant artillery piece
shelling your city,
I think you would assume worse after
awhile,
but some historians say this is all part
of a of a concerted effort that what the
Germans are trying to do with their army
is shock the allies into a pro German
piece and shelling parish as a way of of
of working the other flank sort of on
that.
I'm pushing you British armies back.
I'm shelling Paris and believe me,
it certainly makes clear to the French,
the stakes involved here.
The Germans are close enough to be
shelling Paris.
Now.
The key to this battle is going to be
how the generals utilize the reserves
that they have.
Not to get too technical,
but,
but in this level of warfare,
when troops are fighting each other in
modern combat,
they're wearing each other down and
whittling away their strength and so
generals have at their disposal troops
that they're holding back and where they
decide to commit those troops as part of
the art of generalship.
It's part of what wins or loses battles
and it's part of what the generals are
so concerned about.
When they launched these offensives,
at least half the offensives half the
punches we'll throw in Kaiser sherlocked
are nothing but efforts to divert
reserves from where he really wants to
punch,
but we're alluding to have decided to
do,
is to throw,
you know,
some of these vital and limited
reserves,
which are all these wonderful storm
troopers.
These,
um,
Ernst Junger says they're all kind of
young,
long haired sort of wild man as opposed
to the sort of buzz cut Germans.
It's interesting to talk about storm
troop culture.
I had understood them to be members of
the of the best and brightest,
simply pulled out,
but younger makes him sound like some
sort of ultra cool set of long haired
German viking youngsters or something.
Nonetheless,
you don't have a ton of them,
so where are you going to use them?
Luton.
Dorf decides to throw them into where
the British army,
the fifth army and the Third Army where
they're bulging back like 40 miles and
see if you can smash through to this
important railway junction,
but he runs into the same problems that
the British and the French could have
warned him about that these first world
war armies run into when they try to
launch a fences and continue them day
after day after day.
They simply break down and they break
down on multiple levels.
First of all,
the logistical and supply problems are
immense and their immense for the armies
that still have a lot of good stuff like
the British and the French to the
Germans who were down to like,
you know,
horses that are underfed and not even
enough of them to try to move supply up.
These battles are huge challenges.
At one point,
some of these really important German
armies and sort of ironic ended up
conquering and pushing into the
territory that they had deliberately
destroyed in a scorched earth policy to
hamper their opponents and now they had
to try to operate in it.
The German army right next door to the
army that moved through the scorched
earth territory,
ended up going through the old som
battlefield with all its craters and
barbed wire and you know,
the graveyards of the dead and all this.
I mean,
so both these armies were kind of in bad
terrain.
Now they're attacking and more and more,
you know,
the,
the allies are resisting heroically and
the supply is huge.
The German army's starving in some cases
and you know when you read like the
memoirs of Luton door feel,
say something like,
well supply.
I didn't keep up or some little comment
like that as a reason why you know these
battles bogged down,
but when you actually read accounts of
what these troops who are desperately
trying to get the guns and the bullets,
but more importantly even the food to
these people who are at what they called
the tip of the spear or the head of the
snake.
The combat troops are actually fighting.
They're being shelled and shot at while
they.
They try to overcome supply difficulties
that once you hear them,
you sit there and go,
why?
It's a miracle.
They got as far as they did.
Historian Alexander Watson has a
reminiscence by one of these German
supply troops who realizes that winning
or losing the war requires that they get
their stuff up to the front,
but listen to what they have to contend
with and then magnify this across an
entire 40 or 50 mile front as they try
to move forward and continue to keep
this momentum.
As the supply lines get stretched longer
and the German says,
quote,
I have the feeling that we've been
marching in the wrong direction.
We asked on several occasions,
but don't receive any useful
information,
and in the meantime,
Tommy,
their pet name for the British recall
begins to shoot and not at all badly.
I thus right on ahead and come upon too
recently shot up carts and two dead
horses through a miracle.
The driver remains unhurt.
They warned us that we should not drive
past for in front it's hell,
but what can you do therefore forwards?
Now,
however,
the way begins to get bad,
thick mud makes forward progress
difficult.
And soon we have a supply column stuck
fast in front of us.
A Saxon bridging unit cannot go any
further.
It approaches us and gets stuck.
We therefore harness the horses,
push,
make room,
unload the bridging unit stuff,
et Cetera,
all in the deepest darkness and with the
least possible noise.
In addition,
the shells crash around,
but one no longer worries about them
after much effort,
the wagons or got back on the road and
we think now the comrade in his column
who missed their way can go on,
but no just then a narrow gauge train
comes rushing along.
Irresponsible chaps have thrown
munitions on the rails.
One jolt and the train is derailed on
exactly that street along which we have
to pass what to do with unspeakable
effort to munitions which are jammed at
the front,
are removed.
The derailed carriage is lifted by means
of a winch and then the route is free.
Now the vehicles can get through and
they start up again.
We then come to the worst part of the
road.
Thick clay allows us to go forward only
gradually at every moment a wagon and
it's driver gets stuck.
Reserved teams are sent forward.
Bridges over streams are especially
difficult to cross and on top of that
we're under heavy fire
and to quote,
but the fact that the troops aren't
getting supplies becomes part of the
reason why they can't continue to push
on at the pace that the German high
command wants them to push on the pace
that they're going to have to push on if
they want to achieve these objectives.
Princess Evelyn blue shirt or the
English wife of the German nobleman who
quoted a few times before as a story
about letters that their family was
receiving from family members who were
in these battles and when you read them,
you hear about an army that is literally
starving and exhausted.
She writes,
quote,
they say that no words can describe the
horrors of what they've been through.
They write that they're almost dying of
starvation.
They say they advanced so rapidly that
no provisions could reach them and their
division was five days and nights
fighting incessantly without food or
even sleep at all.
And those of their companies who were
not killed or wounded,
died of exhaustion.
And it is only by a miracle that they
themselves are left to tell the tale.
There letter ends with the significant
words,
quote,
send us some food somehow as quickly as
you can,
or we also show them
die.
End Quote.
She then comments about the situation in
this little village where she lives,
the peasants and village people received
the news that sometimes one,
sometimes even two of their sons had
been killed on the same day.
It has been wholesale slaughter
of light and quote.
Given that situation,
it's not hard to understand how once
these troops began to push forward into
allied controlled area and see the
supply dumps and the stores and all
these things that the allied troops
have.
It's funny,
if you read their accounts,
they think they were suffering,
right?
I mean,
I remember reading one where the guy
said British soldier saying,
you know,
we're eating dog biscuits were
practically starving,
but these Germans come across with these
British forces have.
And they just stopped.
In some cases Gj Meyer quotes a famous
piece
about a soldier investigating why the
advance wasn't moving forward.
A German captain writing about events on
March 26th St.
quote today,
the advance of our infantry stopped
nearer.
I'll bear.
Nobody could understand why our airmen
had reported no enemy between our bear.
And um,
yeah,
the enemy's guns were only firing now
and again on the very edge of affairs.
Our way seemed entirely clear.
I jumped into a car with orders to find
out what was causing the stoppage at the
front.
As soon as I got near the town,
I began to see curious sites,
strange figures who looked very little
like soldiers and certainly showed no
signs of advancing were making their way
back.
There were men driving cows before them
on a line.
Others who carried a hen under one arm
and a box of note paper under the other
men carrying a bottle of wine under
their arm.
And another one opened in their hand,
man who had torn a silk drawing room,
curtain Rod,
and we're dragging it to the rear as a
useful piece of loot men with writing
paper and colored notebooks.
Evidently they'd founded desirable to
sack a or shop men dressed up in comic
disguise.
Men with top hats on their heads,
men staggering men who could hardly
walk.
When I got into the town,
the streets were running with wine out
of a seller came a lieutenant of the
second marine division helpless and in
despair.
I asked him what is going to happen?
It was essential for them to get
forward.
Immediately.
He replied solemnly and emphatically.
I cannot get my men out of the seller
without bloodshed and to quote,
but in addition to the logistical and
supply exhaustion,
there's another kind of exhaustion that
plays into all these world war one
offensives and it's human exhaustion.
It's the part where human beings simply
come to the end of their limit.
You know,
when you,
when you can fight a battle the way you
want to,
you rotate people out.
So after a unit is so tired,
they're not useful anymore,
you know,
you take them out of the line and you
replace them by fresh troops.
But in these battles,
and especially on the German side,
this was very difficult to do
and they didn't.
So the same troops are fighting for days
and they're dropping where they stand.
I mean,
if you believe the princess blue shirt
letter,
they're dying from exhaustion,
but if you think about how being this
tired affects your ability to resist and
your willingness to continue onward,
I mean we're sitting in the comfort of
our recording studio here,
overwhelmed by these people's ability to
put up with the shelling and the
conditions and the dead bodies and all
that stuff,
but that's when you think of them having
a full belly and a good night's sleep.
Imagine it when you haven't slept in
days and you're starving to death and
the Second World War.
Some of these armies will sometimes use
things like amphetamines to prolong the
amount of time people could endure
before they hit the exhaustion point.
I've seen it blamed by some historians
for some of the more infamous massacres.
You have troops that had been up for 12
days straight using speed.
They might not be as rational or as I'm
collected as,
um,
they might've been 12 days previously.
I'm part of why these exhausted soldiers
aren't able to force anything to a
conclusion that they're,
they're moving forward.
They've been successful.
They've been reinforced.
But they don't have any mobility
throughout all of human history.
Cavalry had sort of played the role of
what they needed.
Now,
someone that could rush forward and
attack retreating or troops who are at
least pulling back really so you know
all sorts of chaos in the enemy rear.
The Germans need tanks and they need
armored personnel carriers and they
won't have it for another world war.
Their opponents do have these things.
They unveiled the tank a year before
this time period and they've become
better and are getting continually
better at figuring out how to use it.
Initially the German high command had
scoffed at this whole tank idea,
but they're taking it more and more
seriously as time goes on.
They wish they had some tanks.
Now I bet because these exhausted
soldiers are only able to march forward,
historian John Terraine considers this
to have been almost criminal,
that the German high command launches
these offensives to win the war,
but don't give the troops any way to
exploit their victory.
He said,
quote,
as the year would show,
the days of cavalry is an arm of
exploitation on the modern battlefield.
We're over yet feeble as it was the
cavalry was the only exploiting arm that
existed for the Germans to launch an
offensive intended to win the war with
none at all was not just foolish,
it was criminal end quote,
and it would allow the enemy to move
reserves and help,
and the French have unleashed divisions
of troops that come to the aid to and
the resistance of the allies will
stiffen heroically,
you know,
in front of this important railway
juncture,
and the Germans would run out of gas.
Essentially.
They would be like that wave that lost
the momentum at the end of the beach and
Luton Dorf years later.
Writing in his memoir is about what he
knows is this important moment in his
history.
Germany's history,
world history,
and that he's been criticized for a ton
and here's the way he puts it.
In his memoirs,
quote,
the enemy's line was now becoming denser
and in places they were even attacking
themselves.
While our armies were no longer strong
enough to overcome them,
unaided the ammunition was not
sufficient and supply became difficult.
The repair of roads and railways was
taking too long in spite of all of our
preparations.
You then goes on to say it was an
established fact that the enemy's
resistance was beyond our strength and
quote on April Fifth Ludendorff calls
off Operation Michael.
He's inflicted 178,000
casualties on the British Bam in 15
days,
77,000
on the French,
but he suffered between 230 and 250,000
casualties himself.
For a man who launched this whole attack
out of a fear that American
reinforcements were going to come and
swamp the Germans through sheer numbers.
You can't trade lives at this rate and
survive.
Alluded.
Dorf knows that,
but he's going to continue to punch
because that's his plan.
He's hoping to land a clean shot
somewhere.
The problem is is that there was so much
invested in Michael.
These offenses that had been planned for
months always do the best.
The troops.
Morale was always at its highest.
The failure was disheartening and the
dead on the German side come
disproportionately from their very best
handpicked troops.
When you decide to use most of the
rocket fuel and the very first punch,
you don't have a ton left for subsequent
punches,
and at this point Luton door starts
getting really pointed,
not so nice questions from subordinates
about what's he thinking here?
What are you going to do?
Some of Lewd and door staff is turning
against him.
They're openly questioning his decision
making in these situations.
At least one of [inaudible] responses to
his rebellious staff members made it
into the history books he supposed to
have said,
and one historian described it as acidly
quote,
what is the purpose of your croaking?
What do you want from me and my now to
conclude peace at any price and quote,
they'll hum von Liebig who will be a
field marshal in the next world.
War is openly critical of Luton,
Dorff and then says that on March 30,
first he totally lost his nerves and
quote,
this is sorta the way they described a
nervous breakdown back then,
and if Ludendorff had had one here and
he may have had another one or he may
have had the first one later,
there is going to be an increasingly
period ahead for Luton Dorff and he's
already showing signs of cracking.
If he'd had one,
then that would just put him as the
second German military leader in this
war to have a nervous breakdown.
The original architect who had to carry
out the plan to win the war at the very
start of the war,
have on mold.
He also lost his nerves.
Now you say to yourself,
who cares?
Why does it matter?
But if gluten Dorf is still basically
the guy making all these decisions on
what to do with all these punches and
how to react when opportunities are
crises erupt,
his state of mind is key and if it isn't
clear,
how's his decision making going to be?
It gets questioned increasingly as we
continue onward.
The Second Punch arrives on April ninth,
so right after Michael is called off,
they launched Georgette.
Each of these punches,
as I said,
has its own name.
Georgette was supposed to be George,
but now it's been scaled back,
hence Georgette,
because of the huge losses that the
first punch cost,
the Germans,
Georgette is launched in the north in
flanders against in a really strong
defenses where they've been fighting for
years.
These defenses had been weakened
somewhat though because when the Germans
were busy throwing their first punch
Hagen,
the British were rushing every unit that
they could spare down to where the
fighting was and a bunch of those units
had been up here in Flanders.
A lot of what Ludendorff is going to do
with these punches,
as we said,
Mr,
create diversions.
It'd be the equivalent in a boxing match
of throwing a punch at someone's body to
get them to pull their hands down,
opening up their head,
and go to another punch.
This is where Ludina Dorf really wants
to win the war though,
because up in the north here in
Flanders,
his goal are the channel ports.
These ports right on the other side of
the English Channel from Great Britain
that are supplying everything,
the entire British army and in fact all
of the stuff that they're bringing in,
you know,
to share with the French and everything
else.
It's a key area.
Everybody knows it and when Georgette
strikes,
once again,
Luton,
Doris got foggy weather helping him out
and once again he somehow strikes units
that are just shouldn't be in the line
of fire.
They were actually moved to what was
thought was a quiet part of the line and
then boom,
you have another German hurricane
bombardment.
You have still some storm troopers left
who were pursuing through this fog,
a poor Portuguese division.
This is truly becoming a world war now
that we're supposed to be leaving.
The front that day gets just
disintegrates in front of the artillery
fire.
A British unit pulls back and you have a
very similar situation to exactly how
Michael started this German penetration,
another soil,
your underpants moment when Haig once
again pleads for you.
No help from the French and he gets
some,
but it's sort of stingy in his mind.
How much he gets.
Remember Fatia squirreling away troops
for this counterattack he wants to
launch when the Germans are totally
punched out,
but he has to gamble that he can be
stingy with troops and not have Haig
fold up.
No one knows whether or not that can
happen.
Haig issues,
one of his most famous speeches or
proclamations,
I guess you would say,
it's called the backs to the wall
proclamation and it is literally one of
those stand or die orders to the troops.
Very famous,
very stirring and rousing when the
situation is grim quote.
Many amongst us are now tired to those.
I would say that victory will belong to
the side which holds out the longest.
The French army is moving rapidly and in
great force to our support.
There is no other course open to watch,
but to fight it out,
every position must be held to the last
man.
There must be no retirement with our
backs to the wall and believing in the
justice of our cause.
Each one of us must fight onto the end.
The safety of our homes and the freedom
of man kind of like depends upon the
conduct of each one of us at this
critical moment in the quote.
Nonetheless.
Again,
Doodoo,
ferocious resistance.
I mean you have to think of both sides
is absolutely straining to the maximum.
The British and the French are able to
hold,
once again,
the logistical supplies and the human
exhaustion and the casualty levels,
you know,
destroy the momentum of the German
attack.
Again,
it's,
it's a mirror image.
It's the same thing that the allies have
had to face the last couple of years
when they tried to launch a fences and
then continue to maintain the momentum.
Georgette gets to within five miles of a
key objective and both sides by the way.
Oh yeah.
It's going to be mind numbing.
Suffer another 110,000
casualties each.
It's hard to get your mind around the
numbers.
I always think,
you know,
you figure 50 to 60,000
people fill up your average sports
stadium,
so you're a hundred and 10,000
number is,
you know,
a couple of sports stadiums and George
yet by the way is small.
That's why it's named Georgette.
The big encounters are giving you,
you know,
multi hundreds of thousands of people on
May 27th,
almost a month later.
Luton door throws the third punch and
it's a month later because it took that
long to in a refit and reorganize and
send replacements and have people in the
hospital that didn't have major wounds
get sent back to the front.
I mean the exhaustion was such that it
took a month to recover so that they
could launch another one of these
punches and it's called operation blue
shirt and within a couple of days the
French are discussing,
abandoning Paris,
moving the government to Bordeaux.
The British are panicked that if the
French fold up here and it's a real
possibility that they will.
That the British army will be trapped on
the continent,
on French soil.
They will be hostages in the minds of
some of these people that we're
discussing coming up with a plan to get
the troops out of France,
hostages to a an arm twisting German
peace agreement right before the
Americans can come and save Europe with
their massive numbers of people the
British would have had to knuckle under
after the French were defeated in their
army,
in its hundreds of thousands or low
millions be held by the Germans for
leverage.
What we've seen happen here is a replay
of what we saw in both Michael and
George,
yet where the Germans again have an
initial breakthrough that shocking and
unlike operation Michael were the
Germans broke through and there really
wasn't any super fantastic goal that
they could strike at this time.
When they breakthrough,
it's near Paris.
The French capital Luton.
Dorf decides to reinforce this attack as
Ian passing him labels him,
and I think it's a pretty good label for
him.
He says he's ever the opportunist,
never the strategist,
but that can be taken kind of as a
compliment to Luton.
Dorf thinks that the ID of pinning
yourself down to one standard recipe,
your set of rules or objectives,
you know,
decreases flexibility and he makes a
move toward Paris.
And we have this crisis again,
another soil your underpants moment.
Ferdinand farash provides as many troops
as he can without totally destroying his
opportunity to have a counter attack in
the near future.
The Americans unready untrained get
thrown into the mix because of the
desperation of the times
they'll fight,
uh,
a small encounter at Chateau t area.
It's called.
And then they'll fight a famous battle
in American military history called
beetle wood.
And the Americans,
when they get into combat for the first
time,
they fight like the Europeans fought in
1914.
No,
they're not particularly enamored with,
with European warfare of what they've
seen and what they've,
you know,
the friendship tried to train them and
stuff.
They'd rather storm up San Juan Hill and
simply take these things.
Why are we being so,
you know,
conniving about it.
And why are we,
you know,
just go up and,
and a little dash and a little American
aggressiveness.
And you'll clear out these trenches and
then these Germans will be on the run
because of this.
The Americans are taking 19,
14 level casualties.
I mean they'll suffer.
10,000
casualties at Bella would boom.
Welcome to the war.
Initial German reports say that the
Americans are almost suicidally,
brave,
very good marksman,
but clumsily lead and the American
artillery,
which is mostly stuff they borrowed from
the French.
They don't have any of their own heavy
artillery,
doesn't know how to do basic things that
the European armies do all the time now,
like a creeping barrage.
That sort of level of cooperation and
sophistication isn't yet part of the
American arsenal,
but it makes it hard to conduct battles
the way the Europeans do at this point.
Luton door says his fear about the
Americans is that they can go and take
over a quiet parts of the line from the
French and British soldiers that are
currently there,
allowing those soldiers to be moved into
positions where they can fight the
Germans.
But there are 10,000
Americans a day arriving in France.
There are almost 300,000
by this time.
In the story,
and there will be 250,000
every month for the foreseeable future.
As the emperor and great military
leader,
Napoleon said about troops,
quantity has a quality all its own.
And what Lewd endorphins going to find
out is that the Americans make damn good
soldiers,
the Canadians and the Australians do two
and several historians,
John Keegan among them,
have started saying that by this point
in the war,
the Canadian and Australian divisions
are the shock armies of the British
army.
The British had lost a ton of their own
units in 1916 at the somme.
And at this point,
the Canadians and the Australians are
healthier,
bigger,
stronger.
You're still getting sorted the pick of
the litter.
Whereas these British formations involve
a lot more people that if you had your
druthers,
should be back in civilian life,
you know,
with kids or still finishing up school
or whatever it might be.
When the Canadians and Australians are
so important at this point in the war
that the German intelligence pays
attention to where they are.
And,
um,
I read somewhere that said that if the
German intelligence saw that the
Canadians and the Australian,
uh,
divisions were right by each other.
They knew that some offensive was going
to happen right there.
One German soldier quoted after being
captured by the Canadians,
uh,
had,
had been shocked because he said,
we thought you were up north,
you know,
they,
they monitored where they were when the
Germans captured the Americans.
What had so impressed them was a
combination of how strong and healthy
the Americans were compared to,
you know,
the way that the soldiers that they were
either encountering or living with war
and also that the equipment was so nice
and pristine and you know,
they marveled at the quality of the
leather and the belt buckles and all
those things.
I mean,
[inaudible] the German army stuff at
this point is we'll trash their kit as
it would be called,
as is trashed.
The guns and whatnot are still good.
But in terms of clothing and whatnot,
the German army is looking pretty
ragged.
There'll be two incidents that are
celebrated in American history that show
the attitude of the Americans is we've
always celebrated it.
One comes during a,
one of these early battles that involve
Americans where they're going into
action with the French,
and there's a moment in time where the
French decided to call a tactical
retreat because sometimes that's the
right move to make,
you know,
from the,
from the playbook.
And they advise the American captain,
a Marine captain,
I believe that he should do the same
thing.
And he famously says,
retreat.
Hell,
we only just got here.
And then there's another famous incident
that has gone down into American
military law,
uh,
from these early battles where the
Americans do too.
Their impetuosity and suicidal bravery
as the German commander might say,
get themselves in trouble under fire and
tall grass with a machine gun,
pinning them down and mowing people
down.
And at a certain point,
one of their officers and old marine who
had been at all the classic pre first
World War marine encounters that had
recently happened from the Spanish
American war to the Philippines to
Central America.
And all that kind of stuff is supposed
to have stood up,
started walking forward,
firing his weapon from the hip and
yelling at all the soldiers that were on
their stomachs in the tall grass.
Come on you.
Sons of bitches.
Do you want to live forever?
Once again,
the ending is a mirror image of the
other punches,
physical and human exhaustion combined
with logistical and supply nightmares
combined with heroic resistance.
Again,
I can't emphasize enough.
These battles on both sides are fought
with the ultimate know,
sort of frenzied striving.
I can't describe it any other way,
but the Germans are starting to get
weaker.
As we said,
they burned their rocket fuel.
They're down to people that they had
planned to be the troops that you put in
the trenches that the better troops had
already conquered to serve in the rear
and just kind of be the last line of
defense and and a lot of their best
weapons were taken and given to the
other troops.
They've never been trained in the new
fire and movement,
the storm troop tactics.
And yet,
these are the people now who have to
make the last few of these punches work
when the better troops at a higher state
of morale at a better time couldn't make
it happen.
The fourth punches thrown June ninth.
It's called [inaudible] now.
And this time you don't see that initial
period where the Germans are able to,
you know,
make great progress before they're
stopped here.
They're just stopped by this time.
The Kaiser sherlocked has cost the
German army between half a million and
750,000
casualties.
Remember this punch of theirs that they
were going to throw was about a million
two,
a million,
300,000
man fist,
and now it's condition is a little like
what the condition of your fist would be
if you had been throwing it multiple
times into a hard object.
First it gets nicked,
then it gets sliced up,
it starts to bleed,
and then it starts to break.
And if that wasn't enough,
there are two other things impacting the
ability of the German army to continue
to fight like this one is perhaps the
worst disease in human history.
Certainly top five on anyone's list in
terms of nasty epidemics,
it's known to history as the Spanish flu
and it probably killed between 50 and
100 million people at a time when the
population was less than 2 billion.
Some 500 million people will come down
with it and in June and July right at
the time when all these encounters are
taking place,
a half million German soldiers have it
in addition to an actual contagion.
They're dealing in the German army now
with an intellectual one.
The fire that Dorf had started in his
next door neighbors apartment is now
coming home to roost and as we said,
it is so hard to figure out from the
memoirs,
you know,
how much of these people are actually
bolsheviks,
how much of them are much more moderate
socialists and how much of it or just
people that have decided that the war
should be over.
Guys like Ludendorff and Hitler,
they put them all in the same category
and by 1918 is the replacements are
coming to these German units.
When they need reinforcements from home.
They are people that have been touched.
Shall we say by the intellectual
contagion,
let loose in Russia by the German high
command to undermine their willingness
to continue the war,
and now they're part of these German
units.
Author Adam Hochschild writes some stuff
on the Americans and then shifts gears
towards this intellectual contagion
issue that Dorf endorphins sort of in a
car makes sort of sense.
Beginning to reap.
He writes,
quote,
in addition to confronting Americans,
eager for battle,
the German high command found danger and
another quarter the impact of the
Russian revolution was beginning to
ripple through the German army.
As its divisions of eastern front troops
were transported to France and Belgium,
the generals discovered that
revolutionary ideas had come with them,
having read German language newspapers
distributed by the Bolsheviks or
fraternized with soldiers from the fast
dissolving.
Russian army.
Many had lost.
All Ardor for combat.
Quote are victorious army on the eastern
front became rotten with bolshevism.
A senior German general told an American
newspaper after the war quote,
we got to the point where we did not
dare transfer.
A certain of our eastern division is to
the west end quote.
Hochschild continues,
quote,
soldiers shipped to the western front,
turned rowdy,
firing shots from train windows and from
one troop train in May,
19,
18 carrying 631 men 83 deserted along
the way.
Cynical troops chocked capital for
flanders on the side of the railway
cars,
taking them west and in half a dozen
German cities underground network sprang
up to aid deserters,
left sympathizers provided men with
shelter,
money,
forged papers and ration cards and
instructions on the best spots to slip
across the border into neutral Holland.
And quote
a little over a month
after the fourth German Punch denies now
is halted quickly.
Ludin Dorf throws the fifth punch.
And by the way,
he's planning on a sixth punch up in
flanders again where Georgette just
failed.
But first this fifth punch maybe to draw
reserves away from Flanders and to who
knows,
you know,
punch a hole and see what happens.
It's known to history as the second
battle of the Marne.
And the reason why people remember this
name so well is because instead of the
Germans breaking through and having this
early success at the second battle of
the Marne,
they get hammered back.
They launch a pincer movement at a,
at a couple of French cities in one side
of the pincer is immediately stopped.
The other side,
you know,
goes on for a couple of days,
slow grinding advance,
and then it stopped.
And then the French military leader,
the Generalissimo now of the allied on
ton forces,
Ferdinand foshe launches a counter
attack.
Now,
historians disagree over whether or not
this counterattack counts as the
beginning of the big counter attack that
foss has been saving up for.
Some say it does.
Others say that this counter attack is
more something designed to stop this
battle.
And the next countertack is the
beginning of the big push.
Nonetheless,
within two days of the second battle of
the Marne being launched by Luton Dorf,
the allies are counterattacking
and they're doing it using essentially
second world war tactics.
They hit the Germans in the flank,
they hit a part of the salient that's a
rear area essentially.
And the Germans are,
they're trying to cut down some wheat
that they've just advanced into because
they're starving and then with no
warning at all and artillery barrage
just starts and instead of it,
you know,
hitting various positions all over the
place,
the shells instantly come together to
form one of those creeping barrages,
those walls of explosions.
And then the creeping barrage instantly
starts moving forward like a giant
moving hurricane heading toward German
troops behind this hurricane of shells.
This wall of explosions is a giant smoke
screen and charging out of a forest
where they've been hiding our hundreds
of light tanks
followed by infantry and with aircrafts
swooping down,
conducting what we call now ground
attack missions,
which is something that did not even
exist three years previously.
These tanks didn't either.
Not only are these tanks and you know,
hundreds of them in one place is very
uncommon.
These are a new kind of tanked,
a light tank that even Ludin Dorf has to
acknowledge in his memoirs,
made a big difference because they're
fast.
Well,
they can move at the speed of a jogging
man where the heavy tanks,
which are the size of a school bus and
have 15 to 20 people in the move at the
speed of a walking man,
hundreds of the tanks at once make a
huge difference as well,
and what their job is is to go take out
the things that are so damaging to the
infantry,
thereby making it safe for the infantry
to advance.
Remember what the first World War did
was combined a bunch of new weapons
systems together.
The changed everything to have the most
important of them were machine guns and
barbed wire.
The first thing these tanks do is crush
the barbed wire and go after the machine
guns.
Machine guns can't hurt the tanks and
what they basically do,
they often don't even use their guns.
They often just drive right over the
machine gun nest,
any of their crushed the people inside
or force them to flee,
but this opens up the battlefield for
the infantry who are following close
behind Luton.
Dorf also mentions in his memoirs that
the French are using.
He calls them tanks that hold infantry
and he says,
this infantry drives up in the tank onto
the battlefield.
Dismounts sets up a machine gun nest and
the and the tank goes back to pick up
more infantry.
He's basically describing armored
personnel carriers.
These generals throughout this war have
been accused of being unimaginative.
Butchers are figuring out how to
overcome the challenges of early 20th
century warfare.
The Germans on their side have some very
forward thinking generals who are good
at this.
The allies do to one of them's a
Canadian guy,
another is an Australian general,
um,
Korean monash,
and they're coming up with new tactics.
The French have generals who were coming
up with new tactics and together they
are overcoming the traditional things
that slow down and offense,
you might call it a form of Provo
Blitzkrieg,
American soldier,
Elton Emac,
and was at this counter attack and had
been told that there wouldn't be a
preliminary barrage that this wall of
steel,
this moving wall of steel would just
appear instantly and in the infantry
would rushing afterwards.
And he describes the situation like this
quote.
One instant there was silence and then
the world went mad in a smashing burst
of sound.
Men caught off.
Balance were hurled to the earth,
which shook against the guns minds.
Stupefied refused all function for a
moment and rebuild everything within 100
yards was nod in bitter tearing bites at
men and trees and wire.
The stately forest melted beneath a
raging storm of fire and steel,
heavy branches and tree trunks crush the
life out for men who coward among the
roots for shelter.
One heard a furious,
awful screaming.
As the shell fire rolled away,
then mad waves of charging infantry came
after it mopping up and quote this
allied counter offensive puts an end to
all those punches that the German army
had been throwing.
Ludendorff will very quickly cancel that
punch.
He was thinking about throwing up in
flanders again and he'll put the German
army on the defensive and the German
army has now reached a point in this war
that is,
you know,
you see it in a lot of wars actually,
but it's that.
It's that point when you're not
defeated,
but you can no longer when,
how you play that card,
when your Delta is very interesting
and once again makes us wonder about,
you know,
how sound the mind of the man who's
going to play this card is during this
time period,
Luton Dorf has been spotted by
subordinates crying.
At one point they will carefully
convinced him to go see a psychiatrist
and the exchange is actually almost a
little comical.
I mean,
you know,
these are human beings and we should
have some sympathy,
but at the same time the,
the psychiatrist is saying things like,
you never get out.
You never smelled the air.
What was the last time you had some good
food?
You know,
it's,
it's just sort of a,
you never think about yourself and
Ludendorff is going,
yes,
you're right.
It's all true,
but what can I do?
And then later says that the war has
taken everything.
In one sense,
he's not exaggerating.
Soon after the German Michael Offensive
Starts,
Luton Dorf motors into territory that
had been recently conquered by the
Germans and some of this ground
contained graves and Luton door pulls up
in the car.
The story goes,
has them dig up the remains in one of
the graves,
and he identifies his son,
also named Eric Luton Dorf.
Now this is a stepson actually,
but supposedly he was as close to them
as biological sons and this was the
second son that he'd lost in this war.
Also the second pilot,
and you know,
it's interesting to sort of compare and
contrast.
This is the last war where you see a lot
of famous,
powerful,
important people lose their children in
the war.
I can't think of another time period
after this where it's been anything
quite like this.
I mean,
not only just alluded to or Flus,
two step sons,
but just off the top of my head,
the prime minister who Britain,
you know,
went through the first two or so years
of the war with Herbert Asquith.
He lost a son,
Ferdinand Foshe,
the generalist demo of the allies.
He lost a son.
And famously when he had been told the
news,
he was busy in the middle of an
offensive and doing stuff,
he was told the news,
he gave himself a half hour to grieve,
composed himself and got back to work.
Theodore Roosevelt,
the famous junkie,
encouraged his kids to get involved.
And then last one,
a pilot also.
It's hard to know how much losing his
second son in this war affected Luton.
Dorf.
I'm tempted to feel it gets just one
more straw weighing down the camel's
back.
And he's in one of these positions,
you know,
I'm,
I'm always fascinated by the extreme
human situations and Luton Doris in one
of those positions now in history.
And there's a lot of people who've been
in them whether under this extreme
crushing stress.
And I always wonder how much they can
take.
And is there a limit that everyone has
or could you plug some other person with
some other personality type in the
situation,
ludendorff scene and have them do
better.
May Look at adults.
Hitler in the last four months of the
Second World War.
He's under this crushing sword of
Damocles pressure and he's this palsy
rec.
Could you put someone else in that role
and had them do much better?
I don't know where the limits of human
endurance are,
but you know it's a question that's
valid across the board.
You don't just want to ask it about the
people at the top of the food chain,
like the lewd endorse.
You also want to ask it about the
soldiers collectively in the fight,
how long can they endure,
and also about the people back home.
Remember,
one of the things that this war really
inaugurated as the idea of total war,
although you can go back to other times
in history and you see it,
but in the modern era,
total war means the involvement of the
what's called the home front and all the
people are needed in this endeavor
because they produce,
if nothing else,
you know all the munitions and
everything.
The troops at the front need to keep
fighting.
What happens when they reach the limits
of their endurance.
Now,
this last part of the war in the last
couple of months,
we'll be known as the hundred days is
one of those,
you know,
it's not a heavily studied part of the
war because it's not like the trench
warfare part of the first world war,
but it's one of those occurrences that
that when you read it,
it brings strange emotions to the fore
because what you're watching is a sort
of a doomed effort and the costs of the
doomed effort are beyond belief and so
as you watch it,
you don't know what to think because
there's something unbelievably admirable
about the people in this story's
willingness to sacrifice all for
whatever reason,
but part of you just screams out at what
appears to a person not in that
situation.
And let's be honest,
raised on much more cynical,
modern values.
What appears to be,
frankly not that smart,
right?
If you think that the war is over and
you are looking at it from the early 20,
first century as we are and you watch
these go through unbelievable things to
prolong it,
you know,
one second longer or something you can't
help but feel like you want to scream
out against the collective waste of it.
All right?
You know,
if you know that this is done,
why let this continue and it's a strange
emotion.
As I said,
there's something heroic about the last
several months of the war
and one side of the heroism and,
and,
and again for people in the 21st
century,
it's,
it's a little strange because we have
the second world war intervening in the
way we think about things in the second
world war really had a good and evil
feel to it.
The first world war was sold as a good
and evil war and the people at the time
period kind of treated it that way,
but a hundred years later as we are now,
you can look back on it and see.
It's really not a good evil war.
It's really more of a old line,
you know,
power of politics,
uh,
international relations.
I mean,
it's,
it's pretty representative in the much
larger scale,
the kind of wars people have always
fought.
And once you do that,
you can begin to see everyone's
sacrifice in a certain light.
And as I said,
in a strange way,
the light that these people sacrifice
really takes on in the last several
months of the war is his heroism and the
very old grand sense of the term and
maybe a sort of a doomed heroism.
And as we said before,
you know,
there's a very toll can ask feeling to
the first world war.
And many people will say that that's not
an accident token.
As we've mentioned in an earlier
episode,
was in this war as a soldier started
writing the stuff that would become
things like the Lord of the rings,
you know,
in this conflict based certain scenes of
the Lord of the rings on things he'd
seen in this war.
And the way that token sort of underpins
his whole Lord of the rings story is a
last alliance of the grand old peoples
that used to be so powerful to take down
the dark power and then you know,
one of two things can happen.
Either they could lose to the dark power
and everything will be covered in
darkness or they can beat the dark
power,
but in so doing will so damage
themselves that they're,
you know,
high water mark on the world stage will
also be over.
It's a doomed victory.
And that's kind of what we're watching
in these last couple of months of the
war were a frightfully high amount of
damage is being done to all sides in
this effort to bring what's now a
foregone conclusion to an end.
These people are dying over terms.
Maybe you know,
can we kill enough of the enemy to make
them give us a little more leeway on
this point in a peace treaty?
That's what these people are really
dying for.
But they're dying in such large numbers
that these will be mortal wounds really
to the British and the French empires.
And if mortal wounds in terms of
replaceability,
because eventually you can replace those
people,
may be mortal wounds on an imperial
psyche whose cost was now appearing to
be unsustainable.
On August eighth,
the allied powers launched the long
awaited counterattack,
the punch back against the exhausted
German forces in the hopes that you can
snap back like a rubber band.
Everything that they had taken in the
past couple of months,
they have washed up to the top of the
beach as we said,
the tide that had run out of momentum.
And on August eighth,
they were hit with such extreme violence
in in several places that Ludin door,
we'll call it the black day of the
German army in the history of this war,
and he'll call it that.
Not so much because the Germans were
smashed and pushed backward,
but they were,
but because it seemed to be the first
real confirmation that the morale limits
had been reached.
At least for some of these soldiers.
There were a ton of surrenders,
for example,
which is what had happened a couple of
weeks before when the French had
launched that battle with all those
light tanks.
A lot of Germans surrendered.
Now they did again here and they didn't
surrender in ones or twos.
You know guys that had been cornered in
shell holes.
They came in groups heavily armed men
led by junior officers who would
surrender to the first allied officer.
They ran into
30,
50,
75 men at a time.
It was it.
It was a sign of something different
because the Germans didn't do this.
It was a sign that we were reaching the
limits of endurance.
At least for some of these units.
The army had become brittle and on
August eighth you see that because some
elements of the army held firm,
but when you're trying to keep a solid
line,
if it gives away anywhere,
the enemy streams through that and then
surrounds all the other position,
turning them into little islands amongst
the enemy.
And one of my favorite stories from
August eighth because it really brings
forward this sense of confusion is I'm
an officer in the second line of Defense
who's in a bunker on a telephone trying
to get news of what the heck's going on.
He could hear stuff.
It's foggy that day,
which is kind of like Mother Nature,
uh,
decided to equal the odds because it had
been foggy through so many of the
punches.
The Germans had recently thrown in
there.
Nineteen,
18,
spring offensive.
It seems only fair.
It would be foggy.
You know,
the day the allies,
countertack,
and it is in that bunker commander says
you can't even see 10 feet out there.
And then as he's on the phone trying to
figure out what's going on in aid comes
down the stairs and says that the lines
are broken and the enemy is,
has,
has bypassed this readout and is behind
them.
And he says that before the person
speaking even gets the whole message
out,
the grenades are rolling down his into
his bunker.
In other words,
the enemies.
They are already throwing grenades.
So to sum up how August eighth looked
and the allies,
um,
in the north up,
I'm,
yeah,
the British who are using the Canadians
and Australians as we said,
as sort of shock armies,
use 500 plus tanks.
And most of them are the big heavy ones
that,
that are like school buses.
And they have the aircraft come in and
do the ground attack missions.
They have the infantry come out,
they use the,
the,
the wall of shelves,
but no preliminary bombardment and
German units just break in front of
them.
The French have success,
you know,
in theirs that they launch a couple of
hours later and the allies are pushing
through German lines and making what by
first world war standards is great
progress.
Here's how historian Nick Lloyd
describes the day,
quote,
eighth August would be one of the most
remarkable days of the war.
Although the position of all units was
not known.
The ally to salted,
driven between six and eight miles into
German lines,
shattering the second army and unhinging
the flank of the 18th army on its left
German casualties had been staggering.
The official history estimated that they
were as high as 48,000
men,
including 33,000
missing or taken prisoner.
400 guns had been lost as well as
hundreds of machine guns and trench
mortars for the battalions in the front
line.
Often only small groups of survivors
remained.
He then continues,
quote,
numerous frontline battalions had been
reduced to the size of companies.
All that remained were clusters of
shellshocked.
Men there will utterly broken their
faces,
grimy their eyes,
glassy,
staring straight ahead.
Their stories were always the same.
Horrifying accounts of iron monsters
clinking out of the mists towards them
of mass infantry attacks of being cut
off and surrounded of waiting for
counter attacks that never came.
Some did not,
or perhaps could not say anything at
all.
Ludina doors,
worst nightmare was it seemed coming
true and quote in his memoirs is very
suspect and take it with a grain of salt
memoirs,
Ludin Dorf claims to have sent an
observer to go and check out the scene
where these units were breaking and he
says,
the observer came back and said that the
troops at the front line were yelling at
the reserves as they came up to take
their place.
Black legs strike breakers.
You're prolonging the war,
and Luton Dorf pointed out that there
was no way to hide.
Now,
you know the changes in the fighting
efficiency as he called it,
of the troops,
they become brittle.
You couldn't depend on some of them.
Ludina says,
of course,
that I warned you about this all the
time.
It's the bolshevism taking hold.
He wanted to shoot more of them maybe as
a way to stiffen the defense,
but then he says that this convinced him
that the war had to be ended and then
some history say that the Kaiser a day
or two later comes to the conclusion
after talking with them that the war had
to be ended and then other histories say
other things.
I mean,
I don't even know how to describe all of
the uncertainties as people try to
figure out what really happened as
opposed to what ended up in the history
books.
There's a lot of evidence to suggest
that Ludin Dorff was more of a hard
liner and held out until much later,
but when you see how again,
the sacrifice that's going to be made
because he may be drags his feet on
peace negotiations,
for example.
That's a hard thing to justify after the
war.
If a decision like that costs an extra
hundred or 200,000
casualties,
how do you look your countrymen in the
eye 20,
30 years later?
Right.
I think if I were in Luton doors,
shoes,
I might try after the war to shade
things in the best light to,
I mean one of the tragedies during this
period,
there'll be a German general who is
looking at the incoming list of 18 year
olds and entire age group now being
called up again to be thrown into the
law of this war when it's already
decided and he'll say too bad about the
young blood.
If one of those members of that new crop
of young bloods was your son and you
lost him in that war afterwards,
reading Luton,
Doris memoirs,
you might not be too pleased either.
Nonetheless,
after the black day of the German army
on August eighth,
the allies will launch a series of
regular hammer blows at the Germans and
they're all pretty darn awful in between
them.
There's tons of fighting going on.
You know the taking of this machine gun
nest,
the moving into this valley.
It's pretty much constant somewhere up
and down,
the line,
pressure on the German army and the
casualties because now we've reverted
back to open warfare again.
People are not hiding in trenches,
which let's be honest,
are safer than being up above the
trenches,
which is why you had trenches to begin
with,
and the casualties just go through the
roof again at a point in the war where
really they're fighting for improved
terms of an armistice,
right,
and Ludina doors not exactly moving all
that fast.
Supposedly the Kaiser wants to open up
negotiations with the Netherlands,
but it's not really taken off so fast
and you're thinking in your head,
as you look back on this tragedy every
day,
you know all these people dying.
You just want them to hurry rush.
There's a time limit here,
right?
Every day you get a little closer to
armageddon.
Armageddon is exactly what historian
Peter Hart called this period of the
war,
the period after the black day of the
German army,
August eighth,
when multiple punches keep knocking the
Germans backward,
eventually knocking them back into those
prepared defenses that they had,
you know,
move forward from months ago and
everybody takes up their positions again
and then the allies smashed through that
heart says quote,
the allied armies,
British,
French,
American and Belgian moved forward along
most of the western front.
They were winning.
All right,
but casualties were still high.
This was a truly murderous form of
warfare.
It's a sobering statistic that of the
one point 2 million men serving in the
British expeditionary force between
August and November,
19,
18,
some 360,000
of them became casualties.
This was unsustainable.
The B e,
F was being consumed.
The French and Americans were also
suffering.
This was armageddon.
End Quote.
Again,
it reminds you of an almost tokenistic
situation where the good guys,
even if they win,
are going to be a shadow of their former
selves,
but if it was bad for the allies who at
least knew that they were going to win
this situation,
think about what it was like for the
people who are enduring with the
knowledge that whatever they were
fighting for is already a moot point.
Me In passing him writes,
quote,
most of the Kaisers men were now utterly
resigned to the prospect of defeat and
despair that they fought on in places
with such tenacity and in such good
order and never ceases to impress an
amaze.
Many that either witnessed it then or
consider it today,
but it was also a truly awful
experience.
Soldiers bemoaned their plight and he
quotes a German soldier during these
last hundred days of the war.
Our artillery is fired out.
We have too few horses are fresh troops
are anemic.
Boys in need of rest who cannot carry a
pack but merely know how to die by
thousands.
They understand nothing about warfare.
They simply go and let themselves be
shot down.
The summer of 1918 has been the most
bloody and the most terrible.
Every man here knows we are losing the
war still.
The campaign goes on,
the dying goes on,
and to quote
again,
that's another guy who might not want to
read Luton,
Doris Morris.
After the war,
after the war,
the great German historian,
military historian,
Hans Dell,
Brooke,
will be a scathing critique of Luton
Dorff and with the same kind of rage
that anyone might have from that
generation and even that side of the
war.
When you realize that maybe several
hundred thousand casualties were
unnecessary.
As we said,
the weird human emotion that comes into
play though is that when you look at the
sacrifices and the endurance of these
people,
you can't help but notice the heroism in
it,
right?
It's.
It's a strange thing,
Lloyd George knows that though the
British prime minister in his memoirs in
a part that you can't really spin,
goes out of his way to just talk about
how amazing the whole thing was.
He says,
quote,
the ceaseless body blows delivered with
increasing power by the allied forces,
left the German army breathless and
helpless,
but it is fair to acknowledge that they
retreated fighting for every kilometer
that they ultimately
had to concede.
It was not a chase and hardly a pursuit,
starved,
decimated,
despairing.
The German soldiers fought on making us
pay a heavy price for every mile.
We wrestled from them throughout the
whole war.
The Germans had shown themselves dowdy
fighters,
but there was nothing finer in their
record than the pluck with which they
continue to withstand us in the hour of
their defeat.
They could not,
but know that they were beaten at home.
Their families were starving.
Yet in the month of October,
the last whole month of the war,
the British forces in France suffered
over 120,000
battle casualties as evidence of the
resistance they encountered between July
first and the conclusion of hostilities,
the British battle casualties in
fighting a beaten pho and a foe that
knew he was beaten on every front
totaled 430,000
killed wounded prisoners and missing
during practically the same period.
The French lost 531,000
men and the Americans over 200,000
let us do honor to a brave people with
whom we've had,
but one deadly quarrel.
They fought to the end with desperate
valor and quote American historian Scott
Stevenson wrote quote to be a German
defender in the path of a major allied
attack late in the war was to experience
the horrors of Dante's inferno
and quote and truthfully,
when you read the stories,
they sound like they could come from any
part of this nightmare.
The worst tragedy here is that you get
the feeling like all of this is,
you know,
coming after the time when this conflict
should be ended already.
If the whole thing is already tragic.
This is the extra tragic part.
Historian Nick Lloyd talks about a
German gunner named Ernst Keel.
Meyer who recorded in his diary about
the fighting going on in late September,
early October.
He writes about his experience of coming
under sustained British artillery
bombardment,
including a direct hit.
He talks about three men and says that
they were quote torn apart beyond
recognition.
And then he said,
oh Lord,
what a Monday morning and said,
quote,
I'm firing on gun number four all day in
between,
we picked up the pieces of bone and
flesh and put them in a box.
I'm mark them with a red pencil,
my companion at all times so that the
cemetery official will know as their
metal plates with names and ranks could
not be found.
Try to pick up three heads,
six arms and feet and whatever else
there is left from your friends then.
And the historian Nick Lloyd Wright's
quote,
Keel.
Meyer was understandably traumatized by
his experiences.
Quote,
if that's how three of us die,
he wrote,
I hope their families will never find
out.
And to quote,
and again,
as we've done it earlier in this piece,
I want to emphasize that these are the
survivors who go home and make the post
first world war world,
the user water in their memory banks.
These are what they carry with them.
These are what influenced their
politics,
their standards,
their expectations and influences what
they want.
The bitterness.
That is part of of what odd off Hitler
is trying to touch in his audience,
reading his book,
mine comp is the sort of bitterness that
experiences like this generate and they
do so in an entire generation after this
war,
the British and the French will also
have their poets and they're writers and
they're thinkers and they're politics.
I mean when one wonders why they seem so
willing to do whatever it took before
the Second World War,
even if it did involve what we call
today appeasement,
look at what were in those people's
memory banks doing all those
negotiations.
The vast majority of the people that
will be in decision making positions
militarily and politically where people
who were in the first world war.
I'm looking at what they went through
and think of how it changed them
as autumn was beginning to turn to
November in 1918.
Optimists,
we're beginning to think that this work
could be won in 19,
19.
Pessimists still pointed out maybe 19,
20 was more realistic.
If the Germans began a step by step dog,
a defense,
they could hold out for a long time.
You know,
it's worth pointing out too because it's
kind of important that the Germans
aren't on German soil yet they're
retreating,
but they're still on conquered
territory.
Something that they will continually
tell themselves was,
you know,
a a sign that they were never defeated
and something politicians after the war
will play up to write the never defeated
German army always on conquered
territory,
but they're being battered pillar to
post during this last hundred days
offensive.
They will retreat at one point to the
old Hindenburg line.
These great defenses are going to make a
stand.
They'll never break the Hindenburg line
and an American and French forces
breakthrough the Hindenburg line.
Ironically though,
considering all of the debates the
allied commanders and politicians had
been having for years,
the eastern or Western or debate,
where do you put the troops?
Where do you win the war?
Western front or someplace else.
It's someplace else that collapses
first.
In this case,
it's what's called the Balkan front,
and for years the allies had been slowly
but surely building up forces in a place
called Salonika in Greece and doing
nothing with the.
Mainly the British especially joked that
they were the gardeners of Salonica
because they were just sitting around.
A Greek army eventually joins the French
and British army that's there,
the army of Serbia.
Remember Serbia has been conquered,
taken over out of the war now for a
couple of years,
but their army fled with the king at the
head and they've been reconstituted here
at Salonica,
but more people are dying from malaria
there than any military fighting and
then all of
a sudden in September 19,
18,
the allies strike there against a bunch
of Bulgarians who are poorly supplied,
poorly motivated,
and certainly not ready to be hit by
what is now more than 400,000
allied troops and they collapse.
This imperils everything.
And it's funny because if you read the
Western history is written by the
British and the French and the
Americans,
it's clear that to them,
this is a side show thing.
It barely gets a mention sometimes,
but if you read German accounts,
this is a catastrophe.
They get their oil,
a lot of their food from this area.
This will certainly be the last car for
the ostrow Hungarians who are teetering
anyway because this is right by them.
The Ottoman Empire,
you know is one second away from
collapsing too.
This is sort of a final straw,
but it's when Bulgaria drops out of the
war and September 29th,
that Luton door finally breaks down.
No ifs,
ands,
or buts about it.
He goes to the Kaiser and says that the
war must be ended right away.
We need in our midst us right now.
I can't guarantee that the army will be
able to stand another 24 hours.
The German government contacts Woodrow
Wilson,
hoping that they can get a nice deal
from the Americans,
whereas the British and the French are
not feeling very charitable.
Wilson still has,
has his idealistic 14 points out there
and maybe the Germans can get that deal
now.
Looks a lot better to them while they
retreating than it did while they were
advancing
and as German military historian,
Hans Dell Brooke Rights,
and this is the most painful event he's
ever lived through,
and he writes this at the time to the
German public and as the editor of the
book points out,
this is something that would have been
censored three weeks before he wrote it,
right?
It was so anti war or defeatist or
whatever you want to say,
but now at this point in the war,
he's allowed to openly say something
like this quote.
The same day I completed the previous
volume,
the most terrible fate we feared
overcame us.
Our Se front in the Balkans broke
completely open.
The Bulgarians were defeated,
their king abdicated,
and the army of the entente that it's so
long.
Defendant Salonica was on the march to
the Danube River in Syria.
The English not only fought but
destroyed a Turkish army and took
Damascus in Constantinople.
The German allied Turkish government of
ever Talmud is gone.
It will not be long before the English
fleet has free access to the Black Sea.
Austria,
Hungary is also in full disillusion on
the western front.
Our hope that the enemy offensive would
not pass through our siegfried line is
unfulfilled under heavy losses of
prisoners and material,
our army retreats from one place to
another,
the superiority of our combined enemies,
not only in men but also in material
airplanes,
tanks and munitions far exceeds
expectations and calculations.
When we remember how strong we to the
world this past spring
and our battlefield successes from the
21st of March through June are sudden
reverses hard to believe and quote on
October 30th.
The Ottomans drop out of the war on
November third.
The Austrians do.
While all this is going on,
you have this very weird almost month
long period where negotiations are
opening and going on behind the scenes
and and everybody begins to get the
impression that things are happening.
I mean the mood is quickening.
The war is,
is winding to some sort of a conclusion,
but people are still dying in mass
numbers.
Some in the higher ups of the German
navy decide that if the war is going to
end like this,
the German navy is going to go out
heroically and they come up with an idea
for an imperial navy death ride to
Sally,
out with everything you have taken on
the British fleet,
you know when a giant head to head
battle and go down fighting and take as
many of them with you as you can,
which sounds heroic and wonderful.
If you're some admiral somewhere when
news that this is what's going on,
reaches the sailors in the fleet though
who can also see that the war is winding
down.
Everybody's going to get to go home.
It's terrible,
but it's over,
and then they find out they get to be
part of some death ride to save some
honor for a fleet that isn't going to be
around whether the death ride happens or
not.
In a months time they say no
and they begin to rebel.
Riot is not too strong of a word.
First they have mutineers.
Mutineers are captured.
Then the rest of the fleets,
sailors get upset about the mutineers
and long story short,
they end up,
you know,
running through the streets,
taking over the naval city of Keel,
and then they send out runners to other
nearby cities and they begin to spread
an idea,
not that dissimilar from ideas that were
being spread in Russia the year before.
Here is the fire from Luton,
Doris Neighbor's apartment,
finally taking flame in Germany
and there's been a lot of analysis as to
how Bolshevik oriented some of this is
and the truth is most of it isn't.
The left in Germany runs the gamut from
mild Social Democrats all the way to
hardcore what are called spartacists and
everything in between and part of what
will happen over the next six months in
Germany will happen because there's no
agreement on the left at all as to what
should happen except that they're pretty
darn unified about one thing.
The war shouldn't happen anymore.
And as these people spread to other
locations,
city after city goes revolutionary.
The great journalist Philip Gibbs who
was with the allied entente armies as
they,
as they battered the Germans back
towards Germany,
you know,
thinks everything they've been
through through these years of war.
He writes,
quote,
the thought of all the losses on the way
and evolve the futility of this strife
smoked at one's heart.
What fools the Germans had been?
What?
Tragic fools.
What a mad villainy there had been among
rival dynasties and powers and
politicians and people's to lead to this
massacre.
What had one gained out of it all?
Nothing except ruin.
Nothing except great death and poverty
and remorse and revolt and quote,
and as the German armies are collapsing,
gibbs points out that it's not a moment
too soon.
He writes,
quote,
the British Army could not have gone
much farther after November 11th when
the our misdose brought us to a halt for
three months.
Our troops had fought incessantly
storming many villages strongly.
Garrison with machine gunners crossing
many canals under heavy fire,
losing many comrades all along the way.
The pace could not have been kept up.
There is a limit even to the valor of
British troops.
And for a time we had reached that
limit,
there were not many divisions who could
have staggered onto new attacks without
rest and relief.
He then goes on to talk about the French
and the Americans and then says quote
before them,
the German troops were in revolt at last
against the bloody futile sacrifices of
their manhood and people,
a blinding light had come to them
revealing the criminality of their war
lords in this great swindle against
their race.
It was defeat and agony which
enlightened them as most people,
even ourselves are enlightened only by
suffering and disillusionment and never
buy successes.
And quote,
if you read mine comp this moment in the
war is the crucible of Hitler's life.
And he says,
basically what Gibbs said,
you know,
when he finds out about what's going on,
he is recovering from a gas attack in
the hospital and he finds out that this
war is essentially winding down to in
our misdose and the German government
and the allies and especially Woodrow
Wilson or negotiating back and forth as
people die.
And Hitler freaks out.
And then he writes about it in mind
comp.
In a way that is tactically brilliant,
I mean Hitler is a demagogue of the
highest order and knows exactly what
buttons to push in his audience and he
knows that this audience,
you know,
10 years,
15 years after the war,
not even that long in some cases are
still in shock and denial and disbelief
and the bitterness that they're drowning
in thinking of what was lost and who
they knew who was lost in the limbs that
they had lost and the lives that had
changed.
He knew that those buttons were ripe for
exploiting and yet at the same time
demagogue and manipulator though he was
Hitler,
understood those buttons really well
because those were actually the same
buttons that he was so affected by.
He wrote this in mind comp and remember,
imagine
reading this as one of those people
sitting there without an alarm.
Fifteen years after the war,
tortured by that experience still Hitler
says quote,
and so it had all been in vain,
in vain.
All the sacrifices and privations in
vain.
The hunger and thirst of months,
which were often endless in vain.
The hours in which with mortal fear
clutching our hearts,
we nevertheless did our duty and in vain
the deaths of two millions who died
would not the graves of all the hundreds
of thousands open the graves of those
who have faith in the fatherland had
marched fourth,
never to return,
would they not open and send the silent
mud and blood covered heroes back as
spirits of vengeance to the homeland
which had cheated them with such mockery
of the highest sacrifices which a man
can make to his people in this world.
Had they died for this,
the soldiers of August and September 19,
14 was it for this in the autumn of the
same year that the volunteer regiments
marched out after their old comrades.
Was it for this that the boys have 17
sank into the earth of flanders.
Was this the meaning of the sacrifice
which the German mother made to the
father,
land with sore heart as she let her best
love boys march off never to see them
again.
Did all this happen only so that a gang
of wretched criminals could lay hands on
the fatherland
end quote.
This bitterness was not just on the side
of the central powers who lost this war,
though corporate Louis Bar toss in the
French army is,
if nothing else,
almost in sympathy with the German
veterans.
Many of these people felt cheated by the
whole thing,
disillusioned by the whole thing,
exploited even barter.
Sounds like he feels more sympathy for
his German enemy than he does for the
people you know that in his mind anyway,
Bartos is a socialist and believes that
the people running the world are kind of
the enemy.
He writes,
quote.
Meanwhile,
the great drama was reaching its
conclusion alone against 20 nations
baying after her Rena.
Fantastic clamor,
Germany,
so proud in 1914 now on its knees,
asked for mercy,
asked for armistice,
but this way of fleeing the war didn't
appeal to the striped sleeves who didn't
have their fill of crosses.
Metals,
stars,
stripes,
ribbons,
honors and glories.
For these folks,
war had to end with total disaster.
For the German army against which Jenna
Waterloo and sit down would be mere
skirmishes.
Thousands of captured cannon.
Hundreds of thousands of captured
bushes.
Shattered enemy forces streaming back
across the Rhine,
bridges pursued with bayonets at their
backs by our soldiers,
our regimens entering the great cities
beyond the rhine,
flags,
fluttering bands playing here was the
apotheosis dreamed of not only by our
great warriors,
but by the government,
almost all the press,
almost all
the Embas,
gays and back in the rear.
All those who had nothing more to lose
or who had more to gain by continuing
the war.
What did a 100,000,
200,000
more cadavers matter,
a few more months of unimaginable
suffering to bear.
Did that matter for those who were far
from the slug fest,
he says,
and to accomplish this monstrous dream,
the so called allied government sought
to delay for as long as possible the
hour of the last cannon shot by
requiring Germany to repeat its demands
for our Mr several times for simple
questions of form and formulas.
He says during that time in an orgy of
murder,
bloodletting and burning the whole front
was in flames from eap to bell for
without exception.
All the regimens were thrown into the
assault on the German machine guns.
He says,
the German army's been back on all the
points of contact without letting their
line be broken and their retreat didn't
turn into a rout and quote
what you hear.
There is admiration from a soldier to a
soldier and sort of a shared
understanding that when it came right
down to it,
you know truces could be called and they
could go in the middle of no man's land
and share tobacco in chocolate with each
other,
but the people that has bartos had said
earlier in the work force them to fight
each other against their will,
would continue the conflict until things
were just the way they wanted and people
will die until the absolute last minute
of this conflict.
In fact,
they will die for decades afterwards.
The Germans will finally work out a deal
with Woodrow Wilson and the allies and
the entente.
They have to get rid of their form of
government and transitioned to a
republic Ludin.
Dorf offers his resignation at the last
couple of days of October.
It's accepted.
He dons a disguise and flees the
country.
The Kaiser is told that he has to
abdicate to save lives in the end,
the war,
and he tries not to,
but it's kind of he says stabbed in the
back too and kind of forced to and and
he flees to the Netherlands and now this
new German government,
which has been sort of left behind as a
land mine by guys like Ludendorff
Ludendorff famously said,
again,
blaming the socialist and the people
back home.
You know that they did this stab in the
back.
So let them pick up the pieces and let
them get blamed by signing all the
surrender and our Mr papers and that's
kind of the way Ludina started spinning
this whole thing from minute one.
Hitler picked up on that and entire
German political movement will play off
this idea that these people who signed
the peace agreement,
the traders of November,
were the ones who lost the war and that
it was never lost at the front by the
soldiers.
This will set the stage for the next
conflict and when the actual peace
agreement is signed,
sealed,
and delivered,
which won't happen for quite a while.
There'll be long negotiations,
19,
19.
The results are so punitive that people
will realize,
forward thinkers will realize and will
say at the time that this does nothing
but delay the decision and that they
will be so many embittered elements
after this treaty assigned the one that
will actually end the first world war.
It will be a series of treaties actually
that you're guaranteeing another world
war in the near future,
yet one can't help but think of all the
men in uniform,
especially those in combat units at the
front who were just glad that they were
going to have a future and at the 11th
hour of the 11th Day of the 11th month,
11:00
AM,
November 11th,
19,
18 on many different fronts,
soldiers greeted this moment,
this agreed moment.
It's a little strange when the war would
end in advance.
Historian,
soldier and politician,
John Buchan was there at one part of the
front.
The minute the war ended.
Here's what he wrote,
quote at two minutes to 11 opposite the
South African Brigade at the eastern
most point reached by the British
army's,
a German machine gunner after firing off
a belt without a pause,
was seeing to stand up,
take off his helmet,
bow,
and then walk slowly to the rear.
There came a second of expect in silence
and then a curious rippling sound which
observers far behind the front likened
to the noise of a light wind.
It was the sound of men cheering from
the voltage to the sea and quote,
the future may have been poisoned,
but at least these people would be there
to see it.
November 11th will be celebrated after
the war has armistice day and will be
celebrated with a wide mix and range of
emotions.
The war,
however,
had taken the geo political chess map of
the world that had been basically in
place since Napoleon's defeat 100 years
before and throw it up in the air
and as the pieces fell back down to
earth and people tried to reconstruct a
new world really because countries had
been totally removed from the map.
A lot of people were going to suffer.
Part of the reason that the first world
war is so important to our modern time
is that it's a little like a giant
bundle of firecrackers that when you
light it off,
nice big chunks of firecrackers blow off
in the distance and continue to explode
sometimes with more violence than the
original.
I mean that's what the Second World War
is,
right at direct successor Bolshevism and
which leads to the Cold War.
The situation in the Middle East and the
oil and the colonial impact.
The thing about the first world war is
that it wasn't quite armageddon yet.
The very things that probably were
needed to create an absolute global
holocaust hadn't yet entered into the
picture.
Things like nuclear weapons for example,
but I think you can safely say looking
at it that what the first world war was
was a blueprint for Armageddon.
If this were a book,
this would sort of be the postscript
section I guess,
but one of the most interesting aspects
of the first world war is what came
right afterwards,
sort of as a result of it.
It changed so much,
so the catalyst for change itself is
interesting,
but the change,
it ushered in this fascinating
start with the fact that all of a sudden
the the map of Europe,
the Great Geo political chess board that
had existed forever,
was thrown up in the air,
totally scattered and all of a sudden
pieces fell down that hadn't existed.
You know,
in a long time.
All of a sudden,
Poland was back.
There hadn't been a Poland for quite
some time.
All of a sudden there was going to be
like a checklist.
Slovakia.
I mean,
these are places that used to be part of
larger empires,
but those empires were smashed by this
war.
Austria,
Hungary alone.
When you break that up,
you get a bunch of new countries,
you break the Ottoman Empire up,
you get the modern Middle East,
you break Germany up and you get the
arguments for the Second World War,
right?
You get dancing and you get the sudeten
land and what's also a parent at the end
of the first world war is you get this
period of people who are trying to play
the game the way it's always been played
in.
Maybe you could make an argument,
always will be played,
and people who are trying to utilize the
flip side of bitterness,
I guess you could say,
to create a better world.
We talked earlier about Woodrow Wilson
and his idealism or fake idealism
depends on which woodrow Wilson you buy
into,
but nonetheless,
when you sell a war on the idea that it
is a war to end all wars,
sometimes that becomes powerful hype
that you have to at least make a good
argument around if you want to play
things the old fashioned way.
The British and the French,
for example,
make out like winners in the war when it
comes to the territory that they
acquired.
When when the Ottoman Empire broke up,
all those new countries didn't really
get full independence.
Most of them had a sort of a compromise
sovereignty.
Is that a good way to put it with the
French or the British Empire in charge,
that 20th century version of coal thing
oil.
The British will miraculously ended up
with a ton of it,
but the Americans and others had pushed
ideas like self determination and the
British had sorta mild that too,
and they kind of believed it too.
I mean it's.
It's one of those things where as the
prime minister had said,
he kind of would have been remiss if he
didn't grab some of that area,
just let the French habit.
Nonetheless,
they all kind of realized it didn't look
that great with a new set of values in
play,
but self-determination became this weird
thing to know who deserves their own
place and and how can you use self
determination as a weapon.
Hitler would use it against one of those
territories that was created out of
whole cloth by the World War One peace
agreements place called checklist.
Slovakia within that place was a
territory that had a majority of
Germans.
It was called the sudeten land and
Hitler would turn the arguments of
idealism and self determination on their
head when you said,
hey,
if self determination is what you really
believe in,
those Germans in the sudeten land should
be allowed to come back to Germany and
bring their land with them.
This would turn out to be a big problem
and what are called the interwar years.
It would hamstring an entity that was
truly idealistic,
like the League of nations setup after
the first world war by the people who
were,
as I said on the flip side,
sort of have the global bipolar mood.
Instead of being bitter.
Their attitude about the first world war
was a sort of a never again,
out of food and things like the League
of nations and collective security.
We're going to ensure that the world
never had a tragedy like that happen
again.
We emphasize the bitterness at the end
of the last program because the
bitterness helps play into the next war,
but there were a lot of people that
weren't bitter and it's only fair to
point that out.
First of all,
you had people,
a lot of times these were officers too.
It's interesting to note who were so
proud of their war service and what
happened and and justifiably so.
Look what these people endured wouldn't
take anything away from anyone.
Some people straight up enjoy the
experience.
Ernst Junger has a piece in his book
where he does something that I think
many people throughout history have done
when they're at giant historical events.
When you're at a great battle and you
know you're watching history unfold,
sometimes there's a powerful feeling in
that and especially when you think
you're playing a part in it.
On the 50th anniversary of the Normandy
landings,
a d day,
I remember there was a newspaper article
published by an army psychiatrist who
was talking about these kinds of moments
in soldiers' lives and said that for
many of the men you know who were at,
you know de day in the Second World War,
that was the greatest experience of
their lives.
The greatest event they would take part
in historian Neil Ferguson.
In his book,
the pity of war describes the
remembrances of a couple of soldiers who
were probably representative of a whole
lot of these soldiers,
one's a Canadian private talking about,
you know,
what the first world war was to him,
and he said it was quote the greatest
adventure of my life,
the memories of which will remain with
me for the remainder of my days and I
would not have missed it for anything
and quote.
It also had this sort of momentous
feeling that was sometimes tough to in a
recapture and private life.
Ferguson also quoted another soldier
that said,
quote,
everything that happened after the war
was an anticlimax and to quote,
in some ways the war was enhance
anticlimax.
So many people went to fight based on
ideas like the war to end all wars and
yet people who were rather far sighted,
but there were plenty of them before the
smoke had even cleared.
We're predicting the second world war.
I mean the general release Cmo of the
allied on ton forces.
Ferdinand foshe had said when he saw the
Versailles peace treaty,
this is not peace.
This is a 20 year armistice and by the
way was almost 20 years exactly 21.
It looked to the British and the French
like they made out well with territories
that they were able to take over,
but they were both in terms of their
great power status,
mortally wounded.
The eventual cost of this war especially
falls on Britain's shoulders more than
any others.
They were sort of the banker of the
allied side and they are still are or
were recently.
I don't know if there are still
outstanding loans,
but it was only in the last few months
that they paid off one of the
outstanding first world war debts that
were still out there
as we had said in the show,
the the center of World Trade and
banking transferred from London to New
York during this conflict and as a
result of the financial transfer of
wealth from the old world to the new
world that this conflict required as we
had said about token.
This is,
this is the,
you know,
peoples of the free peoples of middle
earth destroying themselves to take down
the dark Lord.
Right?
He's gone.
Imperial Germany's no threat to anyone
anymore,
but France and Britain to name just two
countries or me not even to go into
Russia's backyard and mentioned them.
France and Britain will never quite be
what they were,
the Russians.
Needless to say,
I'm aren't going to be what they are.
They're going to be living under a
communist regime for decades.
The Tsar and his family in the middle of
1918 will be executed by the Bolsheviks.
Every last one of them and the cook,
the United States comes out of the war.
Well actually they're,
they're on the receiving end of all that
old world wealth for example,
but for Americans it was quite a change,
a change that had really started with
the Spanish American war.
You know,
20 or so years before the first world
war when the United States started going
abroad and involving themselves more
overseas.
The first world war solidified that
trend and even though after the war
there would be this mood that,
you know,
we're not doing that again.
You could tell that it's.
It was sort of like virginity,
a barrier had been crossed and you
really just couldn't go back to the way
things were.
We'd find that out as Americans in the
Second World War.
Americans also got to experience other
things that would not be uncommon in
Europe.
Things like sedition and espionage acts
imposed by the Wilson Administration
things to prevent criticism of the war,
antiwar activities,
criminalized laws that are still on the
books and still used today that most
people look back on and still think that
those were extreme overreaches of
presidential authority.
Nonetheless,
you know,
it was the first world war and the
threat was there.
Japan,
as I said,
it would be the United States or Japan
that I would nominate for the big
victories in these wars.
Japan had a relatively easy run of.
It took over anything that was over in
their territory that was German and then
started moving in more to the Asian
mainland already in charge of a lot of
Korean folks.
They started taking over territory that
would eventually morphed into what some
historians now considered to be the
really early stages of the Second World
War.
Because by the time the second world war
breaks out,
the Japanese had been involved in
fighting with the Chinese for years and
some fighting with the Russians to
Turkey will continue to have problems
with violence and ethnic conflict and
modernism.
The fighting will never really stop over
in,
in Anatolia,
and that country will continue to strive
towards a more a national state hood.
They'll go through a period,
uh,
under Kemal Ataturk,
Mustafa Kemal,
um,
that's important.
And their history.
They'll also have to begin to live down
some of the things that were done during
the first world war and famously to
Armenians,
but also to people like a Syrian
Christians,
Greeks.
The Turks had an ethnic problem that
they dealt with sometimes in a very
heavy handed manner.
The Austro-hungarian is also had an
ethnic problem.
They,
along with the Habsburg rulers that had
been in power for centuries,
were wiped away as a result of this war.
And the idea of self determination that
Hitler would be able to use about the
sudeten land and whatnot would begin to
raise ugly sort of questions in places
like India controlled by the British.
But not necessarily because the Indians
wanted it that way.
Trying to clean up after the war is one
of the great efforts of modern times.
First you have the bodies to deal with,
then you have the damage to the.
And then you have the cleanup that
happens,
you know,
in,
in the collective populations of all
these countries,
the emotional cleanup,
if you will,
the getting past it.
All of these societies that were heavily
involved in the first world war will
have a lot of disabled veterans around.
It will be a very visible reminder.
Nobody gets to just put this behind them
and walk away unscathed.
There's a story.
Adam hochschild in his book relates that
dates from the time of these last German
offensive,
you know,
the big last card being played.
That is a perfect example of what was
going on in hundreds of thousands of
homes.
I mean,
there's no question.
It was that many.
I'm just playing that number.
Safe
harsh child talks about these cards that
the officers would send to family
members,
informing them that their child or loved
one was dead or missing.
And he says,
quote
cards float out in a ceaseless stream,
but when it came to Stephen Hog houses,
younger brother,
his parents,
like so many others,
simply received word that in the new
German offensive,
the 23 year old Paul was quote,
missing presumed killed.
End Quote.
He had been seen fighting than falling.
When his units position was overrun
several months later,
the family's hopes were raised when a
fellow officer passed on a rumor that
Paul was wounded and a prisoner in
Germany with male going through contacts
in neutral countries.
Steven got in touch with a passivist
committee in Berlin.
Quote,
I was very glad to be able to set on
foot by this means in search for my
brother Paul,
alas.
No trace of him could be found.
My poor mother for over six months
persisted in the Fonda belief that Paul
would return and quote hochschild
continues.
During that time,
Margaret hobhouse never ceased to write
letters to her son,
although they eventually came back,
marked undeliverable,
returned to sender.
Paul's body was never found and to
quote,
but lots and lots of other peoples were.
And they're still being found.
You know,
you don't know how much of the really
nasty stuff to get into on a program
like this because you don't want to be
gratuitous,
but what you do want to be able to do is
in your mind's eye,
see what these people are seeing,
right?
As we always say,
you can't experience or understand what
they're going through,
but you can try to have the tiniest
little bit of emotional sympathy,
but you kind of have to see things
through their eyes and what they're
seeing is permanently scarring.
The people who have to clean up after
this war are sometimes as traumatized as
the people that have to fight it.
After these last big German offensives
that that last story dealt with,
the boy missing
and presumed killed.
The people who were killed had to be
picked up by somebody.
An American soldier named Robert Hoffman
in August 19,
18 was one of those somebody one day he
writes quote,
did you ever smell a dead mouse?
That will give you about as much idea of
what a group of long dead soldiers
smells like as will one grain of sand
give you an idea of Atlantic city's
beaches.
A group of men were sent to hill two,
oh,
four,
to make a reconnaissance to report on
conditions there as well as to bury the
dead.
The story was a very pathetic one.
He says the men were still lying there
nearly two weeks later,
just as they'd fallen.
I knew all of these men intimately and
it was indeed painful to learn of their
condition.
Some had apparently lived for some time,
had tried to dress their own wounds or
their comrades addressed them,
but later they died.
There I was especially pleased that the
capture of the German soldiers had made
it possible to bring back all the
wounded in our sector.
Many of the men had been pumped full of
machine gun bullets shot almost beyond
recognition.
One hundred or so bullets,
even in a dead man's body is not a
pretty sight.
One of our men was lying with a German
bayonet through him.
Not unlike a pin through a large beetle.
Bayonets are hard to remove when once
they've been caught between the ribs,
especially the Sawtooth Bay,
and that's many of the Germans carried
to dislodge them.
It's usually necessary to shoot once or
more to loosen the bay and net.
This German had not waited,
but left his gun and passed on.
The little Italian boy was lying on the
barbed wire.
His eyes open and his helmet hanging
back on his head.
There had been so much shrapnel that
some of the bodies were torn beyond
recognition.
This was the first experience at
handling and burying the dead for many
of our men.
It was a trying experience as I was to
personally find somewhat later.
He then goes on to say there's nothing
more pitiful than a battlefield after a
battle.
Well,
pitiful.
Yes,
but dangerous is another term we might
use because this cleanup is ongoing.
Even now,
there's a good side and a downside for
the cleanup process with having a war
that doesn't move.
The great mass of Europe and places
elsewhere were spared.
The total sort of ruiness war that the
second world war brought to so many
areas,
but the places where the war was
actually fought were devastated and not
just devastated,
permanently scarred,
maybe permanently ruined.
Certainly for several foreseeable
lifetimes.
Author Donovan Webster wrote a whole
book on the state of those battlefields
in earlier wars today,
and the most polluted,
most dangerous,
most impossible to imagine them ever
cleaning up are all these ones that the
first world war fought on the western
front in these places where things
didn't move for years because the shells
buried themselves in the ground.
I don't remember what the exact
percentage that they that they estimated
the number of duds versus the number of
good shells were,
but since 1946 French specialists have
removed 18 million shells and they
estimate that there's another 12 million
just around Verdun.
The biggest shells,
like those Paris gun shells,
the duds from those are so deep in the
earth,
they won't even make their way to the
surface for 60 years.
Hundreds and hundreds of these people
who go and try to clean up these areas
die.
There've been farmers killed,
there were like 35 killed in one year
when their tractors were hitting shells
and some of these shells,
as you might imagine,
are chemical weapons.
The problems that these people have
trying to reclaim the areas are so bad
that they just have cordoned off the
area since the war and millions upon
millions of acres of France and part of
Belgium are just shut down too
dangerous,
so it's like the world's biggest garbage
dump with human beings all ground up
through it and then it's littered with
booby trapped explosives and chemical
weapons.
Good luck cleaning that moon scape up.
The Germans had thought that they were
signing something more like an
armistice,
more like a succession of hostilities,
more like some deal along the lines of
what they thought Woodrow Wilson was
talking about in the 14 points.
What they ended up with was more like a
surrender and truly given their military
condition.
That's probably what they should have
been doing,
but even as the war was winding down,
ludendorff changed his mind at the last
minute and wanted to restart the
conflict right before the armistice
actually took effect.
Wouldn't that have been,
uh,
interesting.
What if scenario.
Nonetheless,
his army was ready to go home and in a
lot of cases was going home by the end
and the Germans had at least a million
people that they thought were shirking
or not listening to orders or simply
refusing to fight anymore the deal at
the end of the war and the difference
that the Germans thought they were
getting versus what they actually got
was one of the seeds that sews the
future bitterness.
The German navy manages to sort of give
the middle finger to the allies.
You know,
the year after the war is over,
when they're transferring their fleet to
Britain as part of the mandated things
that they had to do with the peace
treaty.
And they intentionally sink a bunch of
the ships.
So they may have rioted against their
own officers at the end of the war.
But that didn't mean they wanted the
former enemy to end up in possession of
their vessels.
I'd also like to quickly mention
something that I think you're aware of
that's been throughout this whole
program,
but the ripples of pain that these wars
and all these deaths and maimings and
suffering's caused the number of people
in a relating to the or civilian who
experienced the horribleness and how
that just radiates across societies.
You can go read the.
The artists have this postwar generation
and and sometimes it's just so
incredibly haunting.
I mean,
you'll read it.
They'll talk about,
for example,
that there are all these women who
sweethearts or patrol,
there are people that,
you know,
they maybe would've married somewhere
down the road,
didn't exist because they died in the
war.
So they ended up spinsters.
I mean just decades of pain in a
rippling through the societies and a
sense of loss.
And oftentimes in some of these nation
states plagued by chaos,
you know,
as they tried to find their new path.
I mean,
Germany is a perfect example.
Rushes and even better one people we're
often confused and sometimes caught up
in the wheels of things that they had no
control over.
How'd you like to be some civilian
living in a country that went fascist on
you or Bolshevik on you,
where that fell apart?
I'd like to point out that the problem
with this story that we did here is the
same problem you often run into if you,
you know,
read or speak in the English language
and you want to,
you know,
get a hold of something about the first
world war.
I've often said that doing these
programs has given me the most sympathy
for the people who actually write these
books and create the materials that we
use as sources for this program,
for example.
Because once you try to do even a pale
imitation of what they're trying to do,
you instantly see,
have all your questions answered,
right?
I'll say,
well,
why didn't they do this?
And then you start to do this kind of a
show yourself and you go,
oh my gosh,
how am I ever going to include this
without screwing something up?
I mean,
if there's anybody who got really
shafted in this story,
I mean,
I,
I can think of numerous peoples who
deserved a ton more time,
but I think we alluded to it earlier.
The French are an enormous part of the
story.
I didn't even get to Clemons,
so that's inexcusable,
right?
How do you even get away with that?
Carlin?
All I can say is look how long this
series is now.
I mean,
I left out tons of stuff to get it down
to this enormous length.
Isn't that terrible?
And what about the people in the
Balkans?
Right?
This is where the whole war begins.
Those are the people who've had an
amazing history right before the first
world war.
They are finding themselves in their
national identity and consciousness is
all coming together.
I mean,
it's a fantastically both traumatic and
dramatic time of change.
I mean,
it's,
it's colorful.
It's interesting.
The situation in the Middle East with
the Ottomans and,
and,
and the modern Middle East beginning to
form Africa got totally shafted in this
story.
Could have been a whole podcast series
on the first World War in Africa and the
Far East is busy setting the stage for
the Pacific War and the Second World War
and we dealt with it minimally as a
point of
explanation though I might point out the
lack of good English works on this
subject.
We have a lot of quotes from Germans,
a lot of quotes from British folks and
their dominions.
A lot of quotes from the United States.
There are not a ton of good books even
on the French where you get a lot of
firsthand accounts from soldiers are
their experiences.
I found one really good one and we've
used it in the show,
but if that guy wasn't at the battle
you're talking about,
all of a sudden the sources are hard to
come by.
Love to have more from the Russian side,
the Balkans,
the Ottomans to Africa would be great to
finally,
there were some subjects we could have
gone into more deeply that I know a lot
of you want.
I mean some of you people geek out about
the military side of history is I do.
We did do some discussions on airplanes
that didn't make it into the show.
We did some deeper stuff on the war
ships that did make it into another
show.
Those will all be rolled together with
some other popery I put together in the
extra show whenever we get that out and
I'm not promising when that happens.
I got another one of the real,
you know,
regular history shows to start working
on right away because you folks have
been patient with me.
This one took longer than any we've ever
had in the past and will.
I guess you could probably see why.
Go look at the reading list.
Be Nice to do a subject that is not as
well documented next time.
Thank you for everything.
Ladies and gentlemen,
do you think the show you just heard is
worth a dollar?
Dan And ben would love to have it.
A buck a show.
It's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.